foreign
good morning uh it's 1002 and we'll go
ahead and get the division three work
session started here
we have several topics today to get to
know the department better
they're listed in the calendar
the first step is going going to be the
office of the commissioner but let's
take also come on up we'll also just of
note
um at 2 30 we're going to begin a work
session on HB 49 and I just was informed
that that may have some conflict with
the Democratic caucus at three
so I I just heard the data and so I'm
still processing what the implications
are I I want to respect your need to
caucus
and balance that with the need to try to
move the bill and the difficulty of
getting division one and three together
at the same time
so so that's that's what I'm going to be
thinking about in background and we
could talk maybe at lunch or something
about your thoughts on that
um
all right so we're missing uh
representative hole I talked to him
today so I think he's alive and uh
representative nordgren is recovering
she's
oh okay good good good good
um and we've checked the streaming and
so
um Mr White uh why don't you uh open us
up with the office of the commissioner
and if somebody could tell me exactly
what budget page we're going to be
looking at as we talk about the office
of the commissioner
it looks like it starts on page 1069.
page 1059 there's 9 10 69. I'm sorry
1069 1069 okay I have a hearing issue
and for those watching at home this is
all
um
online under the fiscal section
10 1069
I got it all right I'm ready good
morning uh members of the committee Mr
chair uh my name is Nathan white I'm the
Chief Financial Officer for the
Department of Health and Human Services
uh today
um we are beginning part one of two
parts on the office of the commissioner
um our objective is to provide you with
an oversight of all of the various
operations that are performed within the
office of the commissioner if you turn
to page two of the document in front of
you we'll be starting off with a
division of finance and procurement and
then I have Melissa sear here the chief
legal officer to discuss the office of
legal and Regulatory Affairs Christine
Alexander our director of Human
Resources will follow that and then Mike
Lawless with the employee assistance
program that that's what we intend to
cover today on Friday we'll be
discussing or presenting on facilities
office of Health Equity I.T and the
division of program quality and
integrity
so that's all good um at what point do
you expect us to go uh taking plunges
into the the Budget prior to the release
of the governor's budget we we were
heavily in the overview and no money
discussion pretty much now we're heavy
into the money discussion so what how do
you see the interplay between this
presentation and uh the the budget
numbers in front of us sure So within
the presentation
um we we have identified the specific
accounting information that we'll be
referring to as as we go through this so
the and my objective is to make it clear
to the committee so that you can tie the
activity or the operational function to
that specific account so rather than
simply going through the governor's
budget book without a lot of contacts
what we're going to be trying to do is
really tie the function to the dollars
and the accounting unit that that's my
goal and you know please let me know if
if we need to make modifications along
the way all right I'm ready excellent
if you turn to page three of the
presentation in front of you
um in I I have a high level overview of
the division of finance and procurement
Mission and the division of finance and
procurement it actually falls within one
single accounting unit
and we have both the financial functions
as well as the Contracting and
procurement functions
if you turn to page four
that is where you'll see the accounting
unit it's 56.76 and in the governor's
in the governor's budget it is on page
1071.
and this is that's genius by the way
thank you for putting the page numbers
on there absolutely absolutely
um and and as I said no if you could
just pause for like 30 seconds because I
want to take a look at the numbers get
get my right side of the brain ready or
left or
so in 1071 I'm reading
office of business operations is but I'm
not seeing anywhere where it says
division of finance and procurement is
is the division within this office yeah
the the entire division is within that
accounting unit and and this is where
this is where through these
presentations what what I want to try to
do is is connect that gap between the
the traditional
um accounting unit name and then the
actual operations all right good
so go ahead
of course so if if you turn to page five
um what I've tried to do here is really
chunk out the various functions that
occur within accounting unit 5676
um on the far side
um think expenditures and and this is
where a vast majority of the FTE
work and and this is really the the
finance team and within
within the uh within our division we
have
um Finance directors in each Finance
director oversees a specific division
area so we have a finance director that
oversees uh the division of long-term
supports and services and the division
of economic stability we have a finance
director director that oversees the
division for children youth and families
and and and and so forth and so on
and um they're responsible for a variety
of functions on a day-to-day basis and
this includes our Surplus deficit
projections our AP management uh
Contracting invoices day-to-day account
management audit activities year
enclosed statutory reporting
um and and the list really continues
this is where a bulk of the financial
work this is where the where the
financial work really takes place we
also have a revenue and Reporting side
of the house as well one of the key
functions there is our CMS 64 report
it's a quarterly report
that that we provide to the federal to
to the federal government there's also
throughout the year over 200 various
reports are filed yes
okay so I'm looking at page 1072 and I'm
looking at uh kind of the middle of the
page where it talks about numbers of
positions permanent classified
unclassified total number of positions
and so I read 158 is is what is in the
current budget
do these numbers on page
five add up to 158
I'm I'm just doing a crosswalk make sure
we're all looking at the same thing
give you some quick math here they they
should
okay so so this so This slide represents
uh the 24 25
request correct and then
um because and it's it's not a it's not
huge but this is a a gain of uh of maybe
seven percent and Manpower over the
current budget
so are you also able to highlight for us
on Slide Five what where where the
additions are going so the the rate
setting team came over to the division
of finance and procurement that was
previously within within the division of
Medicaid there are also a few
conversions of full-time temporary
positions that were converted to
full-time permanent positions
um the presentation that I've provided
on Friday
um I think one of the slides I can't
remember which one we had a net
reduction across the department of of 20
positions total
okay so to summarize
um this is this isn't creeping
bureaucracy this is the movement of
functions and that you've actually taken
a scalpel to reducing some of the ftes
that that that's what's being
represented here on page five yes and
and so if if I can speak to slide five
just to kind of talk about what's
changed all right so so on the revenue
and Reporting they also one of their key
functions is the drawdown of federal
funds and then
um a another unique feature about HHS is
we have a public assistance cost
allocation plan and uh we have a few
folks that manage that and what that
represents is it's several hundred Page
Long document and it articulates to the
federal government the methodology that
we use to allocate federal funds so
there's random moment studies that we
have to keep track of for personnel that
are working on certain functions so that
we we can pay then have a certain Grant
there's random time studies
um as well there's a whole series of
methodologies in that team oversees that
the rate setting to your point uh is is
a function that we moved into finance
and and formalized previously
um there was a there was a function
within the Medicaid team but what we
discovered
was a real need to establish
standardized approaches across the
department for rate setting
methodologies because it's not just
within the division of Medicaid that
that applies so why why would that I'm
going to come to represent Waller in
just a second uh
why
okay the governor's asked for uh 3.1
percent in Medicaid is is is that what
this group of rate setting is meant to
do is to take a look at that 3.1 percent
recommendation uh and offer Alternatives
or what I I if if it's just implementing
3.1 percent across the board it doesn't
seem like you need five people for that
no um that the the organizational change
really had nothing to do with that at
all
um on on a daily on a daily basis
whenever we have state plan Amendment
changes to the Medicaid Program or
waivers these are the individuals that
are deeply involved in that work
um you know we'll be talking about uh
Residential Treatment providers and when
when Joe ribson from the division of
children youth and family comes and this
team has been deeply involved in looking
at the rates within the contracts as
well so
um that that provision that we will
likely see within hb2 that was reference
by the governor really has nothing to do
with the organizational design of this
but they would certainly be involved in
any of that work okay representative
Wallner
thank you get it closer to you if you
would mind yeah thank you
so this is um
I've seen the budget quite a few times
so over the years I think there's been a
different way of doing this and I
remember in the past
each division
had
a finance I don't know if it was called
a finance director or someone who was
did the finances
I think maybe in the last budget we
Consolidated to every all the division
Finance people being under this
group so so historically there was a
finance director that was tied directly
to the division directly and within the
program a number of years ago probably
six or eight
a number of years ago it's it's been a
few biennia
um where we've centralized that that
Financial function
um and and part of that is I mean it's
really by intentional design so that we
can have consistent policies and
procedures consistent approaches across
the department because if we're working
in silos then then naturally we would
have different different outcomes
so that my question is so we moved from
them being attached to the divisions and
the work of those specific divisions to
now coming into a finance department
what is the word I mean how how do they
work with the division how do they what
kinds of day-to-day activity they're so
they're no longer we won't find Finance
people in each division's budget is that
correct yes correct so
the division
supervisors are not supervising the
finance people
correct so how talk to me about how that
relationship Works sure so I I think
each each area I mean part of it just
depends upon the relationship that the
division director has with the financial
director but um most areas have regular
monthly update meetings which are
attended by Bureau Chiefs and the
financial directors
um we have monthly Contracting meetings
that are attended by the division
director and the financial team to make
sure that everybody is on the same page
there there's other regular update
meetings that that are attended by both
parties and then perhaps more
importantly just the necessities of
day-to-day work require that that those
two parties be connected on a regular
basis whenever we have a grant or a
grant evaluation process for new
competitive Awards
um you know that there's conversations
that are occurring so those those are
ongoing through a variety of various
mediums
so do you think that this model
allows the people who work in the
divisions
enough information I mean do they
understand enough about the budget that
their of the work they're directing
yes I I would certainly say so the with
the preparation of the subsequent
presentations that you're going to be
seeing in the coming weeks uh the
financial directors and the division
directors have been have been working
closely on the content of those
um I'm I'm also uh rolling out a new
standardized initiative as well for
um monthly business meetings
um that that retired some time ago I
think as a result of the pandemic but
those are actually going to be starting
here in the coming weeks as well
okay thank you
so um one of the common questions I'm
going to be asking over and over I
should actually I guess it's at least a
couple is um uh what what is our vacancy
rate here and which of these areas are
going to be most affected by planned I.T
upgrades
because we're trying to buy productivity
with RIT upgrades and and I'd like to
know where we're going so it in in the
next couple of slides I'm going to be
addressing some of the I.T initiatives
that we have been working on that are
supported
um roughly I haven't checked today but
last I checked we were hovering right
around 20 some odd percent to 20 so 20
point something a vacancy a vacancy in
this area we've been working hard and
you'll see in our challenges slide that
I have up ahead
um that is one of our bigger challenges
and and critical priorities from my
perspective
okay and when we get to the it it's
going to link back to here and tell me
which of these areas we're most likely
to get productivity gains so that in
next budget we can see some declines in
Manpower so so in my upcoming slides I
might actually show you how some it
initiatives have increased the
efficiencies in this area okay thank you
um
so on Slide Five we also have a
centralized Contracting function and
representative walner we also
historically this was also decentralized
on the department centralized the
Contracting function
probably about eight nine years ago now
in order to standardize our Contracting
and any and gain efficiencies and I'm
going to demonstrate what those look
like and that group facilitates all the
requests for proposals requests for
applications requests for bids and and
other various solicitations contracts
and amendments and mousse and other
various agreements and then finally we
also have a grants management team this
team provides a lot of technical
assistance across the department
as you know much of the many of the
dollars that we do receive are federal
funds uh Federal uniform guidance is a
uh it's due to CFR per 200 applies to
the use of almost all of our federal
funds and then every Federal grant that
we have also has additional final
requirements attached to that this
individual helps and assists provides
technical assistance and training both
internally and to our vendors as well to
help navigate many of the federal rules
and regulations which can be complex
um they also so with only two ftes there
I assume that you've got a
cross-training in place so that you have
a contingency in case you lose one or
two of these people
so Federal uniform guidance and and such
requirements are actually
um they're known by the finance
directors and many of the financial
managers as they they Implement and
execute those on a day-to-day basis so
this individual really acts as a key
repository of information and helps all
the other individuals across the
department interpret and and effectuate
those requirements so is that that's a
yes then
sometimes I do ask yes or no questions
so uh representative Mooney thank you Mr
chairman thank you that CFR citation yes
that first of all I'm going to ask you
what it was exactly so I can write it
down and then second of all that
regulates all federal funds received
from
two DHHS
Federal it's commonly referred to as
Federal uniform guidance
um there's a long history behind it I
won't go into it unless you really want
me to
um but essentially uh was it probably
six six seven years ago the federal
government they centralize all of their
standards before they had various
circulars out there that kind of
contradicted each other left some things
vague and so the central they centralize
all those requirements so that it would
uniformly apply to a vast majority of
the federal dollars that we do receive
and then through if we have a federal
award there may be some additional
requirements reporting requirements
allowability uses things of that nature
that would apply to that specific Grant
um but it's it's two CFR part 200.
and and one key part there that this
individual helps oversee is a system for
sub-recipient monitoring
um that's that's uh to CFR 200 331
um and any any award that we make
um to in in organization or individual
where they are a sub-recipient as
defined within that section other
there's certain requirements that we
have to meet as far as managing and
oversight of those dollars
so
the the grants management team also um
they they oversee the Department's uh
standardized system for evaluating
competitive grants to make sure that a
the grant is in alignment with um with a
department be there are adequate
resources both on the programmatic
revenue reporting Financial Contracting
um and and all other resources that
would be involved with the management of
that Grant so we try to really
thoughtfully before we go and apply for
something make sure that it aligns with
the mission and will will result in
positive outcomes so so my eyes have
drifted up on page 1072 to the revenue
lines where it's Federal in general and
most of this is General
so is there is there a matching
requirement at all in this in this money
or is this just that we happen to be
able to cost allocate to some federal
money and then we're supplementing with
General
we are able to primarily cost allocate
I'm just going to turn to if you turn to
the the budget briefing book
I'm on 1072. so so in front of you
there's the PowerPoint presentation and
then at the back of that is is the
budget briefing book
and if you turn to page
two of that document the budget briefing
book includes all of our accounts that
are in excess of a million dollars
and what we've included there if you if
you scroll down about Midway you'll see
the funding source and
um we have listed all of the various
funding sources that feed into 56.76
okay so to go back to my question I I
think what as I'm looking at the this
funding source segment
in the um
in the office of business operations
this this Revenue this is not matching
money
it so it this is cost allocation that we
can apply to some general funds but sep
or excuse me federal funds but then we
have to supplement it with General funds
to ensure the thing can operate but
there's no there's no matching
requirement here
in this Revenue line
what
primarily no we do have
um one mou that's funded out of class
102 that has a matching requirement but
as if you're if you're talking about
personnel and other class lines well the
total budget I mean this is all agency
income to pay for
um this office of business operations
yes
um with the exception of one mou it's
it's cost allocated the one mou is is a
match without an exact number about how
how what's the value of that mou I
believe it's 350 000. so I'm sorry 350
000. 350. yeah
okay
all right thank you of course
turning to slide six
um and and this is uh speaking to your
your earlier question uh chairman
Edwards
um
these are some of the key key
accomplishments that the team has had
during the past during the current
biennium we are in the process of
implementing a budget business
intelligence tool
um historically and anyone that attends
fiscal committee has probably heard this
conversation historically we have had a
challenge projecting our Revenue
estimates this system will allow us to
do that it's also it should be live here
hopefully by the end of this week it
will also allow me to pretty easily
provide the committee with any questions
so last week representative walner you
had asked the question of where are TANF
funds budgeted
um this system will actually allow us in
a couple of clicks to create a visual
image and show every accounting unit and
the dollars attached to that area so
this is something that the team has been
working on diligently for a long time
now and we are about to see it come to
fruition the centralization of the rate
setting team I already spoke to that I
won't go into that too much
um
we we are also in the process on the
Contracting side and this really speaks
to that efficiency so if we spend money
on I.T so what what does it matter if
we're not getting anything out of it and
um I have a couple of slides after this
that's going to show you some of the
benefits that we've had through some of
the various I.T improvements that we've
implemented on the Contracting side and
we are uh trying to finalize right now a
contract lifecycle management system for
the development of our contracts and
then we are also in the process of
migrating what has historically been an
Excel based solution it's a database of
sorts I wouldn't call it a database
because it's not relational but it's an
Excel file nonetheless into a web-based
application to standardize streamline
allow transparency and better
information sharing and we have also
implemented uh uh in Safe physical year
22 a finance Academy and this team and
some are informally attached to we do
have one full-time person working on
this this team's standard is a actively
working to standardize our internal
processes and establish Dynamic training
so that they're recorded they're updated
on a regular basis so that we when we
have new staff come on board we're able
to teach them through an online series
of trainings this is how travel
reimbursements works this is how cost
allocation 101 works this is how you
should fill out a 170 form all of you
know just just the day-to-day to really
capture that information so that we can
start to plan for the future because if
you turn to the um if you turn oh wait a
minute
because
we we do face within Finance we do have
a number of senior staff that that have
been here for quite some time and in the
next couple of years they will be able
to retire so what we're starting to do
is to try to plan for that that
retirement and that deep loss of
knowledge and standard that standardize
what they know into some of the systems
that we have so that there is not a
complete knowledge Gap when those when
those individuals do indiva retire here
in the coming years yes
so so by the way I think you're doing a
great job so if you're if you're nervous
or anything you don't look nervous but
just you're doing a great job okay
I this budget business intelligence tool
yes uh I I imagine because it's his
budget and the purpose you've stated
here that that is the total potential of
the scope of that intelligence tool
and and let me let me give you some
background on that because DHHS sits on
a tremendous amount of data and
companies are moving more and more to a
data warehouse concept where they can do
Data Mining and they use the phrase
business intelligence to to imply that
they can go data mine their entire data
warehouse and and I I just want to know
where we're going with this tool if this
tool is specifically for the financial
analysis or is it the vendor supported
tool that can do more
so it has yet to go live but it will be
going live soon
um my plan is to utilize this
right now anyway it both as far as
regular updates to the fiscal committee
when it comes to revenue reporting right
now we're able to project expenditure
labs and okay I'm not focused on the you
know within the finance area I'm not
talking about that I really only want to
know if if it's in if it's positioned to
where it will extend beyond have a scope
beyond the financial analysis
to be candid I haven't contemplated that
that's fine it's a it's a geek question
so we can we can skip it it's a great
question though
um I I I I mean we'll keep that in mind
as we move forward and enroll and roll
it out but I'm I'm not I don't yet know
to be candid okay uh well Mr wheaters
will be in here so hopefully I'll
remember to ask him thank you sir
so if you turn to slide seven
um I I had uh made reference to this in
one of our earlier presentations
we we centralize our Contracting
function and again this all falls within
56 accounting unit 5676
and over the past five years
um that team has been under an enormous
amount of organizational change where we
reorganized the the
um the bureau we reclassified our
positions to better we conducted an
analysis of every function that they
perform what are all of the products
what are the rfps the contracts you
supremacist agreements we dug really
deep and we conducted all of that
analysis and then we built that Excel
based system that I was just talking
about that we're now migrating to the
cloud to more of a web-based system we
also implemented DocuSign e-signature
during the pandemic we basically rolled
that out uh in in about two months
design and implementation and we took
what used to be a process that literally
involved us mailing a document them
signing it mailing it back somebody
driving it downtown at the AG's office
AG's office signing it bringing it back
we cut that down from days and weeks to
27 minutes as our record by implementing
that and so the contract life cycle
management piece
um that we that we are in the process of
uh designing and rolling out and testing
right now
um that will basically streamline the
creation of contracts so that instead of
using an email based system you know
where you have three different versions
of the same file
um this will this will have standardized
templates you'll input key data it'll
pre-populate standard forms and then
there'll be a flow where I can send it
to this person it automatically gets
moved on to this person
and and we're really excited about how
much faster we expect that to make the
the process go on on slide eight
um this is the total projects approved
during State fiscal years 2019 2022 by
the contracts unit you'll see in 2019
and 2020 we we had roughly the same
number 2021 was a bit of an anomaly uh
think of that as the pandemic years
um that was a really a really really
busy time where many of the standard
rules were actually removed and the need
to get contracts stood up for vaccine
sites and security at the sites and
um I won't go into it but long story
short think of that as an anomaly but
what you'll see within 2022 is some of
the efficiencies gained we are producing
and getting more items approved and
before GNC at a faster rate than we ever
have historically
and so that's really measuring total
contracts approved volume wise on slide
nine you'll see kind of the trend and
this is the average days for processing
time so back in 2018 it was taking about
142 days and this includes our rfps our
contracts our mousse amendments
everything in totality
um again 2021 was a bit of an anomaly so
you can kind of take that out but even
if you take 2021 out you'll still see
that downward Trend in efficiency so
that we've gone from 142 days down to 95
days
our goal is to continue that Trend with
with the the implementation of contract
lifecycle management because as we've
already discussed we rely on many of our
contractors
before many of the services provided to
the state citizens and and this is a
this is a key vital function to make it
as efficient as possible
I think we have a couple questions here
um
do you do you would you also be able to
map on this I'm not I'm not asking you
to I'm asking if you were would be able
to map the total number of sole source
contracts or the percentage of sole
source contracts because so I I assume
social Source contracts take much less
processing time than the full
competitive route so my guess on 21 is
that we had a higher percentage of sole
source contracts so so yes or no do you
think you have the data that you could
map what the percentage of sole source
Contracting is we could we could
certainly map the percentage of new sole
source contracts if you talk about sole
source amendments that where the rules
actually changed over the past three
years twice so so that data would be a
little bit more meaningless so are the
amendments in in this graph though on
page nine yes that we've averaged
everything out into that figure all
right thank you representative walner
did you have a question yes thanks
so
um
in 21 I mean I see on page eight that
you did considerably
more
contracts I assume that was that arpa
money
um
it was arpa money it was cares dollars
it was a variety of of the um of the
funds that we were receiving from the
federal government but that was
primarily uh the pandemic response
that's why that increases there so are
most of those contracts now been are we
almost to the end of most of those
contracts last I had checked a vast
majority of of those contracts and and
so if if you think back to that time to
have like a single vaccine site stood up
it was supported probably by seven or
eight contracts alone and and we had
those across we also had
um we had agreements with first
responder organizations across the state
uh both public and and non-profit as
well to provide Staffing you know so
think that was probably I don't know I
had probably 70 80 100 uh you know
agreements that we had in place there
and and it was really an anomaly of a
year yeah
I just so you anticipate dropping back
down in the numbers of contracts that
were negotiating back down to more
you know in the area of
800 instead of
looks like you were up to 1200.
I so the the the needs and demands and
and remember this also right this also
includes amendments but the speed of our
business
um historically I don't necessarily know
whether we'd been able to meet all of
that through amendments
um as quickly as we should have been and
so
I don't necessarily know if the past is
a good indicator of the future
um just depending on what does transpire
you know the you know whether there's a
hospital surge a new variant whatever it
might be or a homeless initiative or an
opioid crisis all of these things can
can have a direct impact on the number
of amendments so if we have to amend the
Community Mental Health Center
agreements three times uh for some
reason in a year you know that'll really
bump that up 30 instead of instead of
just one or three
okay thank you of course
so dipping back to page eight for just a
second
um I I can understand
this correlation between the activity
and the pro point in the budget cycle
that we're in uh I'm in again a yes or
no are you all looking to see if there's
potential that could be followed to
smooth this so that you don't get uh use
it or lose it uh scramble at the end of
the budget year
yes and I almost wish I included a slide
I normally include when I present on
Contracting um so back in 2018
as I described it we would have the
roller coaster effect where every April
May and June we would push through
hundreds of contracts and agreements and
so back on the prior slide where I was
talking about some of the initiatives
that the team had engaged in one of them
was an annual forecasting initiative
that was a very methodological approach
where we would provide every division
director this is your list of contracts
that are expiring in 10 11 months what's
the plan and um the the the current
director within contracts Robert Moore
he has since implemented a recurring
um future procurement kind of initiative
where we're having regular feedback to
avoid that kind of spiraling effect
where everything comes due and so I
actually have charts where instead of
seeing this we start to see that kind of
smoothing number to to get to that more
consistent reliable regular uh
production quote-unquote production
environment if you would take an
industrial approach to it that that
should be occurring
um but it's taken years and a tremendous
amount of work to get there
yep
so finally
um on on pay on page 10 some of our key
challenges this will come as no surprise
given our past conversation
um we do sometimes have challenges for
for our entry level positions on the
finance side
um where the salaries aren't sufficient
to attract and and or retain staff
experience is difficult for some of our
mid to senior level positions finding
the right experience
um is is a challenge as I already noted
earlier we do have some retirements that
are on the horizon some of our key
financial director positions could
become vacant here in the coming years
um and then you know just just from a
organizational perspective and um I I
was involved with much of the work on
the contract side I like to Tinker and
reorganize things to meet the business
need and and that can sometimes be a
challenge uh within the classification
system that we have so so the governor's
proposing a 10 across the board pay
raise is is that going to uh ameliorate
these issues or are you still needing
something else to address some of these
concerns
I don't have any data to support this
but my hunch would be that 10 10 percent
in the first year two percent in the
second year would certainly get us to a
place a lot closer to where we need to
be representative hole and then
representative verf and then
representative walner thank you
use the word tinker I like that
um the engineering meets coming up so
I'm thinking about in terms of quality
of employee versus efficiency in Broad
terms is there a sweet spot where less
staff that are better
is a more effective team in some of
these and when I'm looking at entry
level and mid senior level positions
right how do we get to that Paradigm if
in fact that is a better solution
I think there are certain positions
um
that that where you just you need you
need a person
um and I don't necessarily know
you know I I'm gonna have to think about
I think it's a great question I I don't
think that I've performed you know the
qualitative and quantitative analysis
necessary to really give you a a an
answer I can rely on I think I'd really
need to take that one back and think
about that harder
follow up
there are certain positions right entry
level positions is it right whether it's
handling processing processing of forms
those things that are that are far more
right straight labor content but the
management team directly above that that
first level makes a huge difference to
how effective that group is and that's
where I'm trying to focus right that
first year of managers can be either
very effective at running their team or
not so effective and I think
my impression is right these are still
hourly employees and
we might be able to do better so if
there's room for improvement please let
us know
I I think
um one of the challenges that we have is
be given the workloads that we have many
of many of our our managers or even our
finance directors
um and and I think this you'll probably
hear some of this from other division
directors you know we're sometimes
because we are short 20 staff that work
still has to be completed and that has
to be picked up
um by you know class class specs that
that maybe should otherwise be doing
other higher level work or future
planning things of that nature
um to really try to get out of that you
know I I don't want to call it a
reactive cycle but but I but I I think
you know what I'm I'm speaking to
um
I mean I I can I can certainly take that
back and consider but but I think right
now
um we the the the finance team is really
straight out
um frankly
representative
thank you Mr chair regarding your uh at
your level bullet point would it be more
efficient to Target uh increases in pay
to the areas where they're for instance
you mentioned here most um
needed
so I know the department of personnel
um I don't know if they've presented
have they presented to house Finance on
the standard occupancy code overhaul
that they're working on
okay
um and and I don't know if if it would
be beneficial to have the Department
administrative Services kind of speak to
the work that that they have been doing
um so they have been looking at the I
don't know how many it is 972
classifications and and just for
everyone's understanding
um every job in the state has a has a
classification so there's a program
specialist one a program specialist two
a program specialist for and then
there's various
um job you know kind of skills that are
required for each of those and then
those CL then those classifications are
tied to a labor grade and so there could
be 50 you know classifications that are
at labor grade 25 I I don't know I'm
just kind of pulling that off the top of
my head but would they have been working
on is concurrently
what they have been working on is taking
those 975 or whatever they are and
putting those into standard occupancy
codes
which which I believe are issued by the
Bureau of Labor and statistics which
will cut that down I think roughly 170
or something like that so that that but
I I don't know all of the details but I
know that that effort is is being
undertaken to try to simplify the system
and get to some of what you're speaking
to representative Earth so I I don't
know if it'd be best to have the
Department administrative Services speak
to that initiative
um but so let me let me ask you that
question we have some work sessions open
to us those for scheduling in in March I
think is this a topic that you would
like to have Das come in and and brief
specifically on what they've done on on
relooking Personnel classifications
if it's relevant to
the discussion about increasing salaries
across the board relative or not or
doing something more targeted such as
seems to be implied in this in this
bullet point sure I yeah it seems to me
like kind of obvious if we're going to
try to Target we need to talk to das and
ask them what what we already know so so
Mr Ripple what do you think can we can
we schedule them to come in in March
I can schedule that
um would you want them to come in just
to division three or should we do you
think we should try for a full committee
meeting
let's start with the division three and
invite and if we get interest you know
we'll let uh full Finance adopt it but
but we have so many of these kinds of
things in division three that we may be
able to keep them busy for an hour sure
did you have a follow-up either
representative Hull or or Earth okay
then representative walner
thank you so I've been trying to really
understand the 10
increase that was in the governor's
budget for um wages and salaries so
the 10 if if you have an entry-level job
that is empty right now
if you could find Once the 10 goes in
once you could find someone to fill that
position they would have gotten the 10
because the the uh wages would have all
gone up 10 percent
I have not seen the hb2 provision yet
but my understanding is yes that that
would go ahead and apply to those
positions I believe as it's going to be
effective is July 1. okay so even
positions that are not filled now will
still have built into them a ten percent
wage okay that's my understanding thank
you
another shot at it sure apparently I
need more coffee
um so on this 10 and representative erf
was kind of heading there right it's
applied uniformly across all personnel
with little discretion to management on
other than maybe step increases or
position changes in terms of helping
motivate incentivize the key players
what can we do as a committee to help
right make sure right upper management
within the HHS
can retain and grow the key players that
are doing the getting the work done that
you guys want done
so I I mean I think we're really we're
really getting to that Statewide policy
discussion here
um and and I think every you know every
department is going to have a different
perspective I I just want to be
I just want to be sensitive to to the
Statewide policy because it's not only
it's not only impacting DHHS I mean we
we have a we have a classified system
the division of personnel has
um you know oversight over that
um I know that you know there's there's
a collective bargaining agreement that
has to be taken into consideration as
well so I I think it would be difficult
to make any sort of
broad broad policy statements on on my
part just just to keep in mind kind of
like separation of powers like executive
branch versus
um versus legislative branch setting the
policy that I I think that's just my my
only concern there
so Mr Ripple that answer just made me
rethink my earlier answer and we should
go ahead and Tee It Up for full Finance
okay I'll see if I can schedule that all
right thanks
time check uh how much time did we think
we needed or you needed for this and
because it's probably already taken
longer than you anticipated I I think
we're doing okay
um we we have uh licensing regulatory
Services up next if we're if we're ready
to move on
or I don't want to rush you though I
mean I have been rushing you but oh they
are right next so that's a good segment
segue
okay
God I love this
you guys are so squared away with the
page numbers
hi there good morning Melissa Saints
here I'm the chief legal officer for the
department and I oversee the office of
legal and Regulatory services so I'm
going to be here with you for your net
for our kind of next two chunks so the
first chunk being licensing Licensing
and Regulatory Services which includes
both child care licensing and health
facilities licensing and certification
you're going to be telling us how this
relates to what oplc does and what the
distinctions are between yeah absolutely
happy to do so so
um you'll see on the first page the
first slide which is slide 11 that we
have three accounting units activity
accounting units for this child care
licensing being one health facility
Administration being one and Community
residences so we'll go we'll take those
one at a time
so child care licensing ensures all
center-based family based and and also
residential based child care centers are
licensed in the state so it's a it's a
health and safety regulatory oversight
of those of those centers we have New
Hampshire statute we have administrative
Rule and there is also a federal
component related to criminal background
checks and other things that are
involved in licensing child care
licensing we also oversee which is new
to the department for the last two years
uh recreational camps so basically use
summer camps that was something that the
Department of Environmental Services had
before and now it's with the Department
of Health and Human Services Under child
care licensing
Health Facilities Administration is our
other component and health facilities so
there's two components under that
licensing and certification so
certification really has to do with
certifying for payment although it's
regulatory in nature we're looking at
centers for Medicare Medicaid services
basically their regulations and we're
ensuring that they're in compliance with
those regulations so that they can
receive medicare and medicaid funding so
although we don't actually look at
anything related to money at these
buildings we look at health and safety
they have to qualify they have to be on
they have to they have to be in
compliance with those regulations to be
able to receive that funding and if they
do receive that funding then they can
get licensed or if they do receive that
certification excuse me then they can
get licensed there are other health
facilities though that are also licensed
outside of certification assisted living
facilities for example Adult Day Care
Centers those centers don't take
Medicare and Medicaid services they
don't they are usually private pay only
and in those situations they only fall
under state regulations and state laws
because they're only receiving State
funding they're not getting Medicare
Medicaid funding
and so that's the difference between
licensing and certification and we have
one other and I and I can answer your
question one second we have one other
certification which is our community
residences so people that have
developmental disabilities or um or
acquire brain disorders live in
community residences so basically
residents in the community that
um they are cared for and we certify
those residents that they are in
compliance with regulatory with health
and safety standards so that they can
receive payment from our GD
um funding to to or ABD funding to get
uh to get that funding so they have to
be obviously in compliance with with our
certification standards so those are our
those are kind of our buckets if that
makes sense
so I I skimmed ahead on your slide deck
and and of course and I I missed it if
it's in here uh on your child care
licensing yes this is uh the
availability of child care in general is
being mentioned as a Workforce issue
that there's not enough Child Care
availability is there anything about
what's going in and going on in the
child care licensing area that is a
roadblock or another contributing factor
to the challenges of making sure we have
enough child care providers in the state
so our child development Bureau is
really responsible for the development
of child care in in New Hampshire and
that's under long-term supports and
Services I believe right long-term
economics economic housing stability
sorry wrong wrong
um division so they deal with kind of
the development of child care and making
sure that there's enough funding and
those type of things for for them to
sustain our regulatory arm is is the
kind of safety in in health components
to caring for somebody in child care so
when we create our rules our state
regulatory licensing rules we always
engage our stakeholders fully to make
sure that we are not being overburdened
overly burdensome but also being
protective of the children that are
within their care so that's something
that we do and we engage with our
providers all of the time if there's
um barriers or roadblocks or things that
they think that from a regulatory
perspective that we have to look at we
will analyze and see if there is a way
for us to kind of lessen those
regulations there is a federal component
um all child care centers in the state
of New Hampshire have to comply with our
the criminal record check component
which is a federal requirement so we
just execute that we don't have any say
into kind of what goes into that and I
know that that's one kind of bigger
barrier that they feel like that process
is overly burdensome because to work in
a child care center you have to get an
FBI check and you have to get a
fingerprinting and you have to go
through a dcaf registry check and if
you've lived in another state within the
last five years you have to get ready
checks registry checks and criminal
background checks from that area as well
so that process is is over involved and
and it's something that we don't really
have a way to change it although we've
advocated with the federal government we
don't have a way to change it so that I
think is one of the kind of bigger
issues when it comes to onboarding staff
at a child care center so that strikes
me as an area we where most parents
wouldn't want to cut back anyways right
I mean you want to make sure that the
people interacting with your kids are
are absolutely criminals right
absolutely and we have streamlined the
process really well to ensure that you
know what what happens is they are able
to onboard as long as they get their
fingerprints and their federal
background check in and then the other
the other components of the process can
be
um it can take longer and so we have 45
days to comply with the rest of it so
what we've done internally to ensure
that they're getting onboarded as soon
as possible is that we've worked very
closely the department of safety to
ensure that the fingerprints and all
those results get to us really quickly
we're able to turn it around right now
within about 48 hours which is which is
very helpful so it's not it's not a
burden but it is a lot of work for the
child care center representative Wallner
did you have a question here well I was
just going to ask about the background
checks because I think that's been one
of the real real problems in the last
year at least in in child care is
waiting on these background checks
um and so you think now you've gotten it
down I mean people were waiting weeks
months and sometimes for them to come
back yeah and I think some of it was
just education
um we've always been people have always
been able to be onboarded as soon as
their Federal check was done but they
weren't always you know getting the
paperwork or or Expediting that Pro that
part of the process right and so
understanding that that's something hey
if you do this really quickly and you
get this done now we can we can make
sure you're eligible right away then
there's that 45-day component where we
have to do all the other checks the
registry checks out of state stuff
um so people didn't understand I think
that they could be onboarded prior to
and and that they could they have to
work under supervision while they're
still waiting for the rest of that to be
done but I think that there was a just a
lot of communication logic education
that needed to happen and so that that
has been going really really well so for
a while you were doing waivers I believe
yes and you stopped doing the waivers
maybe in December yes we were we were
told by the federal government that
waivers were not allowed we can't waive
federal law so unfortunately we were not
able to do that any longer and since I
mean I know that many child care
providers were really
very concerned at that point yeah
because
um even though I do think they did
understand how to do the paperwork
um
I think there was a real concern about
how long it was going to take if with
that without getting those waivers I
mean the waivers had been good because
they had let people let people start
right work as soon as they got the
fingerprints but so now you're saying
you can do them within 48 Hours yeah and
we always have I think people under
thought that the waiver was something
that they needed for the entirety of
their um the 45-day period that they
were receiving the waivers for that
entire period they really weren't their
waiver was just for that short 48-hour
period while we were waiting for the the
fingerprint check to come in so once
people understood that and that we were
that we were able to actually get them
that information and get them their
clearance by that time that that has
helped a lot I think with um just you
know onboarding and making sure that
people can get into these Child Care
Centers ASAP okay thank you you're
welcome
representative hole thank you chairman
how much on this federal background
check is being done through federal
agencies versus the New Hampshire gun
line it's all done through New Hampshire
it has to be done through the department
of safety and uh so they do all of the
federal check and then we do just the
out-of-state kind of stuff and the dcy I
have to registry check
so
um is this would all go through division
one I assume right in terms of making
sure that the appropriate Staffing is
there to handle yes Department of Safety
isn't working very hard on making sure
that this is done in a timely way from
their perspective as well okay
um so moving on from Health Facilities
licensing and certification I explained
the differences between between those
and then also Community residences there
is one other thing that I just want to
note and that has to do with life safety
which is on page 14 of the slide deck
our life safety and health facilities
construction and renovation staff were
all located within the Department of
Health and Human Services and they have
been for
25 years probably we have to have life
safety inspectors and essentially those
individuals are not only required for
through CMS certification but also
required through licensing that we are
reviewing the environment we're
reviewing fire safety making sure that
you know sprinkler checks are happening
and fire drills are happening and
ensuring that people are in their
environment are safe and what we also
did though which was a little bit
outside of I think the scope of DHHS is
working on construction plans for new
healthcare facilities so you'll see um I
believe it's an hp2 that we are going to
be moving our health facilities
construction plans reviewer position
over to the Fire Marshal's office right
now we have to work with the Fire
Marshal's office if we ever see anything
that's kind of askew or something that
requires a waiver we have to get that
approval from the Fire Marshals office
anyways and so now taking this kind of
Health Facilities construction plans
review positions and putting them over
at the Fire Marshal's Office that will
streamline the process have the you know
somebody who wants to open a new
healthcare Facility have that go
directly to the
um Fire Marshal's Office get the waivers
get the approvals that they need and
then we then pick up once they're
licensed we pick up the review of the
fire drills and the in the sprinkler
systems and all of those kind of Life
Safety components is is is there is
there any potential in these
certifications to rely more heavily on
self-certification with a less frequent
State periodic check and we could slap
some major criminal penalties for a
false self-certification is there have
you guys thought about that so we're not
able to do that for much of our
certification we're required through
certification to ensure CMS and those
centers for Medicare Medicaid services
wouldn't allow us to not comply with all
of those regulatory components and and
part of that is the um the the annual
checks and and those type of things we
have attempted through our recovery
housing which is not under this but it
is something that's in under the
department to do a self-certification
and at this point it's something that we
have this is kind of the first time
we've tried that so we're we're going to
have to see how that goes and and
make some adjustments because there is a
fine line between kind of recovery
housing and then substance use treatment
centers which are residential in nature
and they would actually be licensed so
there's these two components right now
and we're we're moving through that
process to see how that looks
representative Waller
thank you I'm sure that within all of
these documents that are being provided
I could find this information but I
wondered how many facilities in each of
these categories are you
um licensing yep so I um
hold on one second I did have it
we'll get there I promise
page 22.
um this has a lot of information on the
legal Bureau and all the other units
that I haven't discussed yet but the
very first one you'll see child care
licensing right now there's 726 family
and Center based 23 residential programs
and 18 license exam facilities uh
serving over four forty six thousand
seven hundred children and then we have
um also the number of expected youth
recreational camps and then for health
facilities 967 facilities
um and it tells you how many pro concern
complaints we've processed and then how
many certified homes there are and those
are the community residence homes
um and I think that's pretty much it
that's your information great thank you
yep you're welcome
and then
um do you want are you going to talk to
us about your vacancy rates and if any
of these areas can be streamlined made
more productive with automation
certainly
um I can I was planning to say that at
the end but I can go over now for health
facilities and child care licensing if
you'd like
I I don't want to throw you too far off
okay prepared remarks great
so I if everyone's comfortable I can
move on to the Bureau of Legal Services
okay great
so there's many components to Legal
Services as you can see in the counting
units on on page slide deck 15.
we have general counsel under general
counsel there's lots of different
components not just general counsel we
have office of the operation support
Administration
I'm not sure exactly what what the
separation is between those two
we have two ombudsman's offices uh oh
yes
um
we have two ombudsman's offices and we
have an administrative Appeals Unit as
well and legislative services so they
that kind of all they are all in one of
these sections throughout
foreign
so as you can see on slide 16 general
counsel this is a very very high level
overview we have obviously a lot of
litigation within the department so we
have we represent the department in
court we represent the apartment
administrative forums related to
Personnel uh you know any kind of
administrative appeals Hospital
commitments guardianships pursuing debt
owed to the state and and and and more
and general counsel does a lot of
advising so similar to how Finance is
structured we have a general counsel
Bureau that is dedicated to each of the
divisions within the department and some
of them cover multiple divisions some of
them uh you know kind of tag team
certain divisions because if we have
multiple Court hearings on a day one's
you know heading out to New Hampshire
hospital to do a an appeal there and
another one might have something to do
somewhere at the courts a guardianship
or whatnot and so we we really
cross-train and make sure that we can
efficiently
um cover all of the all of the things
that we need to cover within that day so
we have even though they're they are
dedicated we do have a lot of cross
training that goes on and a lot of
people that help in different areas so
there's lots of things here obviously
um auditing uh advising on internal and
external audits responding to lawsuits
Federal compliance policies state laws
and rules investigating Personnel
concerns responding to right to no
requests which are a huge part
unfortunately of the work that we do
contracts and procurement obviously
advising on those type of things HIPAA
compliance promulgating administrative
rules and that's just some of what we
what the legal department does sure sure
as I'm looking at at page 15. I'm seeing
a couple of them but some lines yes but
I'm not seeing a slide writing up what
they do yes we'll get there that's
actually um further in the slides okay
yep I I guess I stopped when I saw the
pdab sorry yeah it's on um
the it's on slide deck 21.
the two ombudsman's offices
okay
all right
thank you just a quick clarification of
course are any of the are you is the
general counsel office handling the uh
sununu Center lawsuit situation or is
that removed so it's removed to an
extent
um the Attorney General's office
represents the department in litigation
matters so if the the department is sued
um that the Attorney General's office
represents the department however
there's lots of Discovery so if there
are documents and things like that that
so those are kind of poured through at
the department by the program staff and
legal to ensure that we're providing
we're responsive to the Discovery
requests and and providing the
appropriate information okay thank you
very much you're welcome
so as I understand the sununu if you're
if if you're a victim you have two doors
you can walk through you can walk
through the the fast more efficient
route of going through the settlement
fund or you could decide that doesn't
work for you and you can go do a
full-blown lawsuit
it's it's my understanding that if they
go through the settlement fund it's it's
much less time and paperwork and effort
for everyone involved than in a
full-blown lawsuit
so the there is a actual entity that's
not affiliated with DHHS that has been
designated for handling with handling
the settlement fund and then there's the
Attorney General's office who's handling
the litigation side of things so if
people are doing the lawsuit so I ca so
although from a department perspective
our our responsibility is gathering the
information ensuring that we're being
um responsive to the Discovery requests
and assisting with those type of things
the time and the processing all happens
outside of the department so I can't
really speak to to your question
okay I guess I just wanted to point out
that there's still two different ways
somebody could go
great so the um as part of also the
Bureau of Legal Services we have two
kind of offshoot units child support and
and dcyf Council child support is
responsible for establishing paternity
and establishment enforcement of child
support and medical support borders so
we have a a lot of attorneys who
represent the the state essentially in
these matters and ensuring that
individuals are getting their child
support and that we're we're also
enforcing those if if anyone is not
compliant with the child with the child
support order
and then we provide general counsel as
well that that unit provides general
counsel to the office of Child Support
Program which is through
um
through the economic and housing
disability division as well
and then dcif council is uh representing
the department and protecting the safety
and well-being of children
um and that is administratively attached
to the department so we help them with
um kind of the administrative needs but
their direction is taken through by the
Attorney General's office so we're
related but we're not it's kind of a
dotted line to to the department but
they are in our budget
I think representative Mooney you have a
question there
thank you for being here uh regarding
caseloads what is the average case count
per employee of your division that's
number one and number two is overtime
I'm looking at that and I can imagine
what big firm life is like and dealing
with these cases and these very critical
and important matters uh how would you
describe over time for your department
so that everything is done efficiently
and as well thoroughly thank you
sure so on on slide deck 22 you can see
our case loads vary
um based off of what exactly we handle
so you'll see there's a general counsel
tab
general counsel that we we broke some of
that down right to no requests 350 or so
a year our estate recoveries annually
recovers about 6.4 million a year that
is placing liens and going to court and
trying to get some of our money back for
to recover some of that client Legal
Services is a is a office that's
identified and created through statute
that receives complaints for those in
the disability developmental disability
program and and other things in the
department so they take about 63
complaints human resource complaints
you'll see AAU approximately 150 we
promulgate about 80 rules every year 320
probate commitments 75 guardianships and
then if you just take General client
Council matters other than kind of the
day-to-day stuff General client Council
matters about 300 or so that need a
legal memo or need you know some type of
document some type of an out legal
analysis that requires a production and
then dcyf we have 8 000 hearings roughly
and about 10 000 open investigations at
the this time child support we average
about 220 hearings a month and HIPAA we
have a roughly about 160 incidences that
we have to investigate and log and
ensure that we're you know doing all of
the investigatory work that we need to
do
as for your question related to how the
department has progressed I think that
we have seen an uptick in in complaints
and other things that we have to have to
investigate obviously you know Federal
Law changes state law changes all of
those things impact the department and
impact every Bureau that we deal with so
as you can imagine over the last three
years there's been a significant shift
in the way that we operate and the way
that we have been able to do things and
it and now we're doing we even have like
the unwind which we're unwinding
Medicaid and that impacts the department
so there's always new things that come
up and I think that although we've
remained fairly steady we have seen a
general uptick in all of these things
including you know responding to write
to no requests and the the breadth of
those right to know requests and the
amount of documents we have to gather
and ensure we're in compliance with the
request so
um you know it's been it is although the
legal unit has not a significant vacancy
rate right now it is and I I'm speaking
just for general counsel dcif is a
totally different story but for general
counsel we haven't seen a huge vacancy
rate we still are
um very very busy everyone is working
many many hours so it's been it is a
challenge but but they're a great group
of people
thank you very much I can imagine the
workload so I'm looking at page 1079
specifically item uh 018 the overtime
there variances any sort of an
explanation with regards to that in
relation to the answer that was just
given
so that is Health Facilities
Administration over time
that you're asking about
I'm sorry am I in the wrong okay I meant
to look at that at legal and Regulatory
services
yeah so if you go
um write down it's 5146 so that this is
specifically to health facilities
Administration which is part of the
office of legal and Regulatory services
okay then for the overtime in your
office then is line
I guess I'm down a bit
um
and I'm sorry your question uh okay
that's more consistent than with what
you're talking thank you very much of
course and and I think one important
thing to point out there
um that with it within that
um accounting unit you do have your
classified in your class 10 and then you
have your unclassified positions in
class 12 and and they don't receive
overtime
um and another another thing that you
may not necessarily see here as well in
certain areas that don't budget over
time they provide them comp time so that
you work you know you work five extra
hours that week at some point six months
down the road you can take those or
maybe not six months but hypothetically
you take five hours off so that it's an
equivalent amount of time off instead of
receiving compensation
representative Earth
thank you Mr chair first I want to say
the relationship between your slides and
the briefing book and the in the budget
is phenomenal it's really great to have
it all tied together like this so
regarding uh 5683 in the budget book
page 18 the financial summary talks
about case loads
and in particular cost per case and I
note that in the in your request the
cost per case is you know sort of
similar to what it is during this
current biennium but in the governor's
budget it jumps up a fair bit to 927 956
dollars per case is there any idea why
the governor
pop that up I I apologize could you
clarify which page you're on page 18 of
the briefing The Briefing book I'm sorry
and this is a great thing this
piece of information
sure so I I mean I can speak generally
to what we're seeing at the department
there's this these the cases that we've
been dealing with have been significant
as you know the the YDC case is one of
those that you um that has already been
mentioned today we have three other kind
of very big lawsuits right now that are
um
that are impacting the amount of
discovery that we're required to do as
well as
um
the uh just overall how how much time
and money and energy we have to put into
responding to these these matters we do
have also from the AAU we have five
temporary positions that we've added and
those temporary positions I was I can
get to later but they are part of the
Medicaid unwind so our Medicaid unwind
requires that you know when we unwind
and take people off of benefits that
they have the right to an appeal and to
handle the the amount of appeals that
were expected we created Five temporary
part-time positions that will likely
span this entire this entire year and
maybe into early next year so that we
can handle the appeals in a timely way
and so those five positions are in this
line item so basically may I continue
so basically between the time you put
the agency request in and the governor's
budget these new things correct became
okay thank you
so I'm sitting here thinking through an
earlier statement that we're seeing case
loads uh increase on
um in dcyf and right to know complaints
and the like
and and I'm trying to understand
uh what the cost of factors might be and
so do we have a more sensitive Community
that's knowing more about how to file a
complaint do we have uh worsening and
services that are triggering more
complaints are we are we keeping track
of historical Trends on the percentages
of cases or complaints that we that we
find to be valid versus you know not
valid uh in the at the end of the day
because because internally I would think
that that's sort of a trend line would
be a a nice warning sign to management
that maybe something's wrong and and so
that's all one question if you can
figure out how to answer sure of course
so we did see a significant uptick
related to the covid pandemic
um the right to no requests from a whole
host of people and those right to know
requests can come from
um you know clearinghouses people that
are trying to just get information so
that they can put it on their website
right and we have the ability we we have
the responsibility to to provide
information so we saw we still see a
large number related to the pandemic and
getting numbers from the department and
sometimes they're very broad they just
kind of say give us everything you have
and so we have to go back to them and
limit them in scope and take some time
to do that so yes I definitely think
there's an uptick
um from the pandemic
we just over the last year and a half or
so have implemented legal files at our
department so we didn't actually have a
file management system from a legal
perspective until that time and so in
implementing that we have been able to
in real time kind of get this
information log these com you know
whether it's a complaint whether it's a
right to know request or whatnot get
them into the system and track and Trend
so I don't have a ton of historical data
other than kind of on paper things that
we used to use on Excel spreadsheets or
whatever and we're we're able to run
reports now that we weren't before so I
think some of that is our efficiency and
helping with us you know understanding
those and hopefully in the future we'll
have more information to be able to
provide
um but you know everything that I know
is anecdotal at this point
and I assume that analysis and that
those um that that information would not
be subject to right to know correct okay
um
I had another question but
representative do you have no
I'll I'll come back to it
I just remembered two years ago we spent
a good deal of time I think uh talking
about
e-discovery tools and and how the
department was spending a tremendous
amount of time trying to you know
freeze records so that they could be
brought in for litigation and and we
talked about industry Trends and
procuring e-discovery systems has any
progress or thought evolved on that so
that is still the that is still the hope
but we have not developed but we have
not purchased the system or or moved
that forward because we've been working
with the Attorney General's office and
and having it be a state a Statewide
system as opposed to a DHHS system
thank you
certainly so moving on legislative
Services I just want to identify we only
have one real legislative Services
person that mostly everyone knows
um but we do have another thing that all
our attorneys do is if they represent a
division they also are the legislative
liaison so you'll see them coming in
they do a lot of legal analysis related
to legislation and also attend hearings
and things like that so that's just
something I wanted to identify here as
well
do you want to talk about you you
actually have two don't you legislative
Liaisons there's Mr Williams and then
there's a woman that does a lot with the
BDS
um so Jenny oh Higgins does public does
um
Behavioral Health
but she is dedicated just to behavioral
health so she's not under the legal
department and then we have
um a whole host of other individuals
that you'll see and probably have worked
with they're all general counsel
attorneys other than John Williams so
John is the only person that's under
legislative Services everyone else is an
attorney that represents the division so
you may have worked with them and think
that they're wonderful and legislative
people but they also have another job
part of their job yeah all right did you
want to say something Miss Roy
she answered the question all right
thank you so the
um prescription drug affordability board
is something that's administratively
attached to the department and I don't
know anything about even though it's in
my accounting unit because I don't
handle it at all so I'm going to let
Nathan speak to it we have a separate
issue on it later today don't we miss
Ripple
there's not a Time dedicated to it but
it is on the agenda for today as part of
the Commissioner's Office overall okay
it was listed last on our I can so it
might be best if I go through the rest
of legal and then we can just catch up
on that one because it's not anything
that I'm really involved in okay great
so we're at slide deck 20 now which is
the administrative Appeals Unit
so uh we handle the administrative
appeals process so it's adjudicative
process that gives Fair Hearings to
appellants recipients of services and
gives a final basically it's it has to
do with final actions by the department
so if the department takes the final
action the aau's jurisdiction is is very
broad so essentially a decision that's
made by by the commissioner and that can
be appealed as long as the person has
the right to an appeal it affects
impacts them it has to do with their
services or whatnot so we have things
like long-term care child abuse and
neglect cases
um Aid aptd or Aid to per to the
permanently totally disabled
um developmental disability eligibility
food stamps home care for children
all of these things durable medical
equipment prescriptions anything that
you can imagine that we make a final
decision related to
um related to a client services they
they can appeal and and this is where
they would appeal is it the
administrative Appeals Unit as I
mentioned already we have so right now
we have six and you'll see it later on
in our key challenges we have six
administrative appeals uh unit hearings
examiners three of those are brand new
um and then we have the unwind coming so
that's the five temporary part-time
positions that we've um we've created to
try to help we are not seeing a lot of
movement on those unfortunately so one
of our key challenges is getting people
recruited into those positions because
they really need we really are going to
need the help if we want to do appeals
in a timely way it can impact if if they
can't appeal and we can't get the appeal
out and we can't get a decision out then
it could impact the budget because we
have to maintain people people maintain
their benefits for the dependency of
their appeal during the pendency of
their appeal so if we can't make a
decision timely it will impact the
amount of time that somebody is
ineligible but remains on Medicaid
during during that appeal so we want to
make sure that we're as timely as
possible but it is going to impact it
could impact the budget so this
administrative Appeals Unit in one of
our challenges this is big this is one
of the big challenges we have
representative Wallner when have you had
any you haven't had any appeals yet we
have not because it only starts April
1st so we expect them to start rolling
in about mid-april okay yep okay and how
long
will people have to do them I think they
have their
15 days
I'll have to check I'm not 100 sure how
many how many days they have to appeal
I'm sorry I can get that information to
you though thanks yeah
great uh so moving on we have now the
ombudsman's offices so we have two
ombudsman's offices one of them is DHHS
Pacific so it essentially is any client
that has a concern with the Department
can contact the ombudsman's office and
they'll act as a kind of a mediator
they'll investigate they'll hopefully
come up with some solutions and
resolutions and so that's what our
general ombudsman's office does and then
our office of long-term care Ombudsman
specifically just deals with long-term
care
our long-term care Ombudsman just deals
with long-term care complaints
somebody's in the long-term care
Community they're in a nursing home
they're an assisted living they can call
the long-term care Ombudsman and the
long-term care Ombudsman operates a
little bit differently in that respect
that they are an advocate an advocate
for the resident where the general Klein
Ombudsman really just helps to kind of
mediate and figure out the problem and
and hopefully solve it for them the
long-term care Ombudsman is really just
an advocate for the resident and and
hopefully they do come to resolution as
well and that's their goal as well
so so that's an interesting dichotomy I
think that the Ombudsman on one will
represent the citizens yes and the other
seems to mediate in between the
department and the citizens they try to
come up with the right answer really is
what they so the federal federal law
actually dictates the office of
long-term care Ombudsman so they tell
them you know you are an advocate for
the resident and it and it you know you
try to get them essentially what they
want
um and be there for them they do though
I mean they do resolve concerns and
complaints right they just facilitate
conversations and things like that they
are in two separate units so they're
headed up by two different people so
they know their responsibilities
um they're not they're not in any way
related even though they're both under
the office of legal and Regulatory
services so I think they do operate both
really well
um but from the Ombudsman perspective
for the DHHS they're not representatives
of DHHS they're not representatives of
the client they're really trying to come
up with a resolution and what's the
right answer are they following the
protocols are they following the rules
are they doing what they should be doing
and that includes telling DHHS hey you
did not do right on this one right and
you need to fix this and and and they
also track and Trend that's something
new that we just added is Salesforce
which is part of the overarching DHHS
product we have now a Ombudsman
component where they can track and Trend
and see okay are we seeing a certain
number of complaints that are coming out
of just this unit like what is going on
with this unit how is it that we can fix
um you know the way that they're
communicating with clients and that kind
of stuff so it's it's actually a really
great tool for both the department and
the client and it's completely
confidential
so if I wanted to uh what happens a lot
I think it happens to all the
legislators is that we'll get a
constituent complaint saying DHHS didn't
do X and the X varies from really minor
things that I I will not minor but
really uh in the weeds kinds of things
that I have no clue what the right
answer is is there is there a One-Stop
shop that is easy to find on the website
for people to file a complaint yes yeah
for sure so the Investments office is
through that website interaction and and
what how that interacts with the public
so we don't actually have a the capacity
on the website for them to update it or
you know kind of type in a complaint the
phone number is listed on the on the
website and they can call and and then
intake will take them take their
information and then it'll get signed
assigned to an ombudsman to handle and
sometimes they when they call they'll
just directly go to and Buds and and
that person will listen and and find out
what the issue is and then work through
it and then it's the Ombudsman who then
takes the Reign at that point and and
they move forward and contact the
program area say what's going on here
and then they investigate and and listen
so that's really the the way to get in
is through the through calling the
muslim's office and that and that's easy
to find on the DHHS website so so it
seems to me that what we would want to
do for our citizens is to let them file
a complaint online with some sort of
summary description of what their issue
is maybe a pull down to help categorize
it and the ability to upload files that
that that would speed so much of that
yeah so I think I don't think that that
I I believe I'm that's not under my
jurisdiction so I don't know but I
believe there is something like that
that's available on the website it just
isn't directly linked to the ombudsman's
office so I'd have to I'd have to speak
with people at the department to see
where that where that might actually be
oh okay so I see Mr White taking notes
are you are you checking this because I
I really would like to understand that
interaction because uh that you know
that's a point of uh
point of care in my view that we should
really make sure is efficient
do you want to say more do you want to
keep going no no I'm I'm good are there
questions here I think uh representative
Stringham uh yeah this you know I do
notice um you know particularly the
long-term care ombudsman's office is
heavily Federal uh supported so I'm
wondering if is this an office they're
requiring you to have or uh is it when
they're heavily incentivizing you to
have so as far as I know all 50 states
have an ombudsman's office
um I don't know if they actually dictate
I mean we've had one for so many years I
don't know if I've ever actually looked
to see if they dictate you know you must
have an office of the Ombudsman or we
can choose to have that so I'll have to
look into that and get back to you thank
you
uh representative walner
so I did notice that your caseload has
really increased in the end budsman
area in the regular Ombudsman yes
yes
what do you attribute that to
so that's something that our that
Salesforce
um I think that part of that is that
we're cataloging them better and we're
keeping better record of them
um not that we weren't cataloging them
before but now we can actually see on
you know in track and trend on an actual
system you know where where we're seeing
increases and
um so I actually uh asked this exact
question when when I got this
information but um we're so they're
compiling so we can look a little bit
more at at that information to see where
what the increase is
and I was wondering if in the office of
long-term care and on budgets during the
pandemic did the
did that caseload increase it did it did
um it was it was really the office of
long-term care Ombudsman as well as the
Bureau of Licensing and certification
provided a lot of support there were a
lot of waivers and things that were
allowable during that time that weren't
before so because the facilities were
able to kind of you know not have
visitors I think that that's really what
we saw from the Ombudsman perspective is
a lot of people calling and saying I
want to see my daughter or the
daughter's calling saying I want to see
my mother you know and it was really it
was really impactful to see how not
being able to allow visitors in and this
was I mean it was a mandate by by the
federal government at that point don't
don't allow visitors if you have any
kind of covid or if you know what not so
I think that that's the increase that we
saw
um generally
I would say that was most of our
increase was just the visitation issues
and we still see it honestly to this day
because there are some nursing homes who
when they do still have covet and feel
uncomfortable allowing visitors in and
it's a much shorter period of time now
you know and they're able to resolve it
quicker but it's still it is still
something that they're seeing complaints
on
well we're on caseloads I I see only 160
incidents on HIPAA
and my guess is that very few of these
are really uh valid correct yeah they're
just investigated and
um we like will have you know an email
went to the wrong I mean even the
smallest the smallest thing that may
have had somebody's name or information
on it
um even if it didn't even have protected
health information we'll still log it in
and investigate it to make sure that
that incident is was either you know an
actual incident and we keep a HIPAA log
as a covered entity we're required to
keep a HIPAA log so we have that all of
that information for anything that's
been investigated and founded as a HIPAA
compliance breach
so just to connect you to another piece
of legislation that's probably going to
pass there's likely to be a privacy
governance board yes and so anticipating
how this information should be shared
with the board yep okay sounds great all
right any other questions here
so the only last thing I have I believe
um other than oh yeah is the active
litigation so we have on slide deck 23
these are
um
in in response to representative
Jewelers question earlier these have to
do with
um all of the cases that are overseen by
the Office of the Attorney General so
these cases are not although the
attorneys in within the department are
not representing the department in these
cases the Attorney General's office are
they still impact the legal Bureau and
the department in general from all
discovery you know Discovery requests
and those type of things and we do a lot
of strategy sessions with them on how to
respond to cases give them a lot of
information on uh you know how to around
our laws because they're not experts in
all of the laws that we deal with every
day so this is just for your information
it's not necessarily anything that we
need to discuss but I wanted to make
sure you had that so so
um I'm curious of the 640 open and
active if we go back to
um like right before the settlement fund
became law what what what has happened
have we seen a a shift to move out of
these lawsuits into the settlement fund
or or is this data basically Frozen at a
prior time so this information I got
from the Attorney General's office just
this past week okay so
up to date yes all right
and then the last thing is key
challenges I think we've kind of touched
them on many of these but wages is one
of them the office of legal and
Regulatory is one of the biggest
challenges is that we need people with
not only higher education in office of
legal and Regulatory but we need people
with experience if you can imagine a
health in say Health Facilities
licensing you can't have a brand new
nurse go in and inspect and make sure
they're complying with all regulations
including standard of practice they're a
brand new nurse typically we're looking
for people that have years of knowledge
years of experience to come in and and
then you they then can regulate so in
trying to engage those individuals and
get them onboarded it does take some
take a higher salary because they're
making a lot more money on the community
and the same thing I mean we have
attorneys here and we need attorneys
that have courtroom experience if
they're going to go and start
representing dcyf
um and matters that are really in
important to the Health and Welfare of
kids we can't just have somebody who's
brand new out of law school going in and
representing these these children so
so that what we're seeing right now the
biggest struggle that we're seeing other
than getting qualified staff in from
Health Facilities is dcyf dcyf is really
struggling in obtaining staff that are
experienced and and want to do the work
that is really it's really hard work I
mean it's very emotional work it's it's
taxing it's a you know caseloads and
whatnot so we are having a very hard
time with DCF right now and I think we
have somewhere between seven and eight
vacancies out of our 28 or so staff we
have seven or eight vacancies right now
and are trying to recruit those but we
have over a lot of overtime a lot of
people covering multiple district
offices and having to kind of traips
around the state to to cover what needs
to be covered
the thing in the middle of BLC is jumped
out at me and and that is that the
department staff are finding more and
more non-compliance if we were to go
look at the root causes of increased
non-compliance is it because these
facilities are also having staffing
issues that's exactly it yep so if we
can help fix those staffing issues we're
going to help fix this problem I hope so
and and then on the wages
paragraph the 10 percent that is
proposed by the governor is is that
going to solve this or or do you need
more you probably need less I imagine
but but what but what do you what do you
think about uh the targeting are these
uh classified in a way or or these
aren't collective bargaining positions
are they the attorneys are well yes they
are yeah actually most of the staff
um the Bureau of Licensing certification
they're all classified employees okay
good to know yep all right and the
answer is yes 10 would be wonderful more
would be great all right thank you
um so legal we already talked about the
litigation and the Personnel Resources
related to Discovery especially in our
huge cases and then the AAU and the
Medicaid unwind I already touched upon
that as well so I think that that is all
I have other than
um what you had for the
drug affordability board
would you like us to speak to that now
or after the HR and EAP
I'm I'm thinking I I I think we we've
lost temporarily a couple of our members
because
um they're testifying in other hearings
I I really would like them to be here
for the prescription drug affordability
board so I'm sorry representative
Merchant I we're just not the division's
just not ready yet I don't think so
let's let's go into HR
and thank you for your testimony
it sounds like you guys have made
progress in the last two years despite
the challenges that's sort of my my
perception
yeah
uh representative Waller I just have a
question for you
um when do you think we will do I mean
um representative Merchant is here and I
just wondered when you thought we would
get back to just so he doesn't have to
hang around or
Puri has other things to do
120.
wow okay not 121. all right it may be if
I just like get lost for a moment but
yeah okay 120. okay
yes sir
all right go ahead
good morning everybody I'm Christine
Alexander I'm the Director of Human
Resources for DHHS I'm here to talk a
little bit about the 31 staff 31 staff
members that I have to support the 3 000
authorized positions for DHHS the vision
for the human resource office is really
to cultivate and to engage with our
staff members to really work with those
Recruitment and Retention numbers
um part of our desire is for us to
increase the expertise and the knowledge
by investing in our Workforce
um with the job market the way it is and
recruitment Evolution we are really
building on our recruitment platforms as
well as our ability to outreach into our
Workforce within the hiring manager
population
um
what we really value in human resources
are internal core values is we really
want to develop our staff we really want
to reduce
processes that are redundant we really
want to make sure that we're respecting
others and our differences which also
leads to Innovation which I love we want
to be able to accept responsibility to
help with the ethical and legal conduct
and business practices which also allows
us to make mistakes and learn from them
but to also increase our knowledge
we also want to make sure that we're
able to communicate in a candid fair and
prompt manner
um I am on the page 27 and the
accounting unit
is
56.77
56.77 thank you
and it's on page 1085 of the governor's
recommended budget
so Human Resources like I said we have
31 positions I have one vacant position
right now part of Human Resources is
myself as the Director we have an
assistant director and then we have five
other departments within Human Resources
we have the Recruitment and onboarding
Department we just recently acquired a
talent acquisition manager who is really
heading and spearing the new recruitment
platforms that we're working on and the
reason why it's Recruitment and
onboarding is there is a understanding
that the retention starts with
recruitment so we're really trying to
streamline that process to engage them
from the start as when they apply in the
applicant tracking system
so is that where the one new fce is
going yes
the vacant one and we just had the new
new position for the talent acquisition
manager okay so we're streamlining by
adding more people well we are
streamlining by using that one person to
work with our hiring managers who are
really the ones that have the touch
points with the applicants okay and and
and so the applicants are finding these
job opportunities online by and large is
that what these new acquisition systems
are that is the hope that is the trend
so right now if anybody wants to
advertise outside they have to find
funding from within the department so
what we have proposed and has been
passed at fiscal would be several
platforms to be able to
um externally post our positions and
actually look for applicants in a
proactive manner sure I'm going to go
back to one of my pet peeves from four
years ago yeah
um when I just thought I would go see
how easy it is to look for jobs in the
in the state government and I want to
the I think the Das website
and it was the worst absolute worst uh
employment opportunity website I have
ever seen I'm sure it was award-winning
and it's poor quality
so what what are we doing different are
we go ahead so with that that is the
Department of administrative Services
that's the division of personnel that
runs the applicant tracking system so so
from my perspective at HHS we have to
work with that within that system in
order for the applicants to apply but
what we're doing is is we're externally
posting these positions to say listen we
have these positions and go into our
wonderful applicant tracking system to
apply and we're trying to lead them
there as easily as possible so by us
being able to
post externally we can lead them into
our system
all right so you're being very Artful I
I what I think I'm hearing you say is
you're developing workarounds so that
you can avoid the Das horrible system
and and it's and and you're seeing some
hope that we're going to be able to
recruit better yes your word it's not
mine no yes yeah I get to be honest I
love that thank you
um no yeah and that's exactly it so I
know that Mr White spoke to the
classification that we classification
with system we have and he specifically
said program supports uh support
specialist one two three uh in the real
world no one really knows what those are
so with these new platforms we're going
to be able to articulate a little bit
more that we are looking for a human
resource
um benefits specialist rather than a
program specialist so we're going to be
able to really Target individuals based
on what their qualifications are and
they're going to be able to look to us
for what we're having to offer rather
than these um vague classification
titles okay but the front door Remains
the Same the Das yes correct
so what are we doing to burn that down
and start over and just come up with a
actual good system well I know that that
would be a Das point of right but you
would be involved right you're like a
key
constituency of the Das yes one yes one
would hope that that collaborative
relationship would continue yes
all right I I I I because every time I
hear we have a Workforce issue I can't
help but to go back in my mind about how
horrible our front door is oh absolutely
and I agree with that and that's one
thing that we are trying your words are
mine
appreciate yeah we are we're really
trying to to work on that and I know
from what I have heard that they are
really trying to update the
um it's called New Hampshire first
they're really trying to update it to
the most modern version but it does take
time in order to get it there so what
we're trying to do is really from our
perspective is get them to just click on
a link so they can go directly into that
job that they're applying for and apply
for it right even just finding the job
you want to apply for is just not easy
the whole search engine thing is broken
and you know you still got switchboard
operators in there and to Mr White's
Point too as well Das Department of
administrative Services is working on
the classification redesign which will
help modernize our classification system
okay I because I I suspect you're doing
an excellent job in every other area I
am but I I your words
yeah we okay but so
so let's just go into your key
accomplishments see if you can summarize
that for us yeah absolutely so I've been
with the state for a year now
um and what we have been able to do is
really recognize that the processes that
we have seen are redundant so we're
really trying to streamline those
processes and it's not necessarily to
the benefit of the HR staff it's to the
benefit of the hiring managers that also
have other jobs that they're doing
besides this hiring Manager work we're
really trying to work on the retention
which will also assist the hiring
managers because then they don't have to
go through the recruitment process yet
again and the retention by engagement is
really how we're working on that so
engaging employees in professional
development and within
um
trainings is really going to help them
and it's also going to encourage them to
stay within the state Service as well I
I I I just can't get off of this uh
website thing
um
are you prohibited from going and
building your own
DHHS portal
recruiting portal um I'm not sure if the
word is prohibited and I haven't
actually even asked that but they are
the ones in charge for the rules of the
applicant tracking system so they're
reporting their metrics on how many
applicants we've had how many those
numbers that is their their role and and
I just just jumping in here I mean I
think from a statutory perspective under
RSA 21i it's it's it's pretty clear from
that that Das is the coordinator of the
state system and I'm sure if we were to
put forward a proposal to doit they
would say why on Earth are you creating
a a shadow system of the existing system
that we already have today so I don't
necessarily think that that would uh be
be an option to today even if it was in
hb2 and you had some language that would
allow you to go do it
I I think I would probably defer to to
commissioner Goulet and and Dave Wieters
on on what that looks like because it's
important to understand and and I'm sure
when Das comes here to to speak to you
it's important to understand that as
Christine was was alluding to the the
larger New Hampshire first system feeds
directly into that website which is why
like you know that database is pulling
from a table program specialist too to
pre-populate like in the title so so I I
think it's there's a lot more behind the
scenes to understand when when
considering any sort of initiative along
those lines
okay well we're good we're hopefully
we're going to make some changes in
streamlining licensing which is another
effort on the part of the legislature to
make Workforce Development
and our acquisition easier
and I just I I do do you think that Das
system is going to be able to keep up
and basically as we change the licensing
requirements adapt rapidly to the new
environment and maybe go out of the
state somehow and recruit and Market
New Hampshire first will not be able to
do that marketing that we're we're
looking to do as it stands right now
okay because like I get indeed ads
telling me I need to go apply that I
could be a forklift truck driver
somewhere they apparently know what I'm
qualified to do yeah and indeed does
pull you know getting into the
recruitment technology it does pull from
New Hampshire first sites but that's
really all that it does so it doesn't
when you click on those ads
it doesn't bring you directly to that
posting it yeah it brings you to the New
Hampshire First Site which then you have
to go search for it so Mr White I know I
think the commissioner said that
Workforce acquisition something like
that is one of her her most important
strategic initiatives
is this part trying to trying to update
and modernize and make effective is this
is this part of her vision of what must
be done
so so I believe the commissioner had
alluded to the fiscal item that the
Department administrative Services had
brought forward to fiscal committee the
other day
um for for licensing for for LinkedIn in
in order to get at exactly what
Christine is talking about as far as
being able to you know using algorithms
to Target potential candidates who live
within the specific region so that
instead of just posting We are then
actively reaching out because I think I
I think you know if if you take that
kind of more proactive approach towards
trying to find individuals then
hopefully that would lead to better
benefits instead of posting it and
hoping hoping for a difference I think
right now
um I I mean I think we'll still have to
work within within the system that the
state has and and I think it's just
really important to make sure that
Department administrative Services
weighs in on that conversation because I
know as as Christine alluded to they are
working to to actively upgrade that
system in the coming years so
okay all right you can go back to where
you think oh wait a second represent a
stream yeah so just quick summary that
what what I understand you have staff of
31 and you're responsible for all three
thousand plus in the HHS uh system
um do you have any responsibilities uh
for Quality Workforce issues versus any
of the critical service providers that
are contracted with is there any overlap
between your function and any of the
contractors at this time no okay
um and second if I may continue uh
unrelated question uh dcyf you know
maybe you know it's virtually on the
verge of of collapsed at a lack of
employment uh and I know we've taken
some action here in the last few weeks
how's it going there and and how how
visible is that uh to you and your team
yeah absolutely so in the fall we
launched a on-site job there we have
been been actively
searching in out externally for job
positions or for the applicants to be
able to fill those positions I'm hopeful
that that 10 increase will also help
gravitate people there as well as being
able to to market the new approach for
dcys as well so we are actively working
with leadership in dcyf to fill those
positions to assist and and and
um also this past September when the
governor and Council were up on the top
of Mount Washington we did bring forward
a number of enhancements requests to to
some of the positions at
um at this at sysc as well just to try
to actively address that um the the HR
team work collaboratively to to get that
work done to try to make sure that we
can recruit and retain staff there to
keep Staffing levels at an appropriate
level
excellent so we were talking a little
bit about the Recruitment and Retention
based on the engagement of employees in
training and professional development we
have also implemented a new hire
orientation again day one when it comes
down to engagement we want to just make
sure that they have
um they are set up for success and they
know where to find the information one
thing as a new hire I wanted to make
sure that it was intuitive for where
they were able to find the information
that they needed and also we do use our
metrics we use our technology to make
sure that we are basing our decisions on
the information that we have it's really
important to us and then we've also
rolled out or rolling out a new learning
management system which will also be
able to help employees and supervisors
learn in time when they are ready so
often we have you know meetings where we
we talk to or educate the employees on
something but that's not their time to
to hear it so basically the learning
management system will allow them to be
able to learn when they are ready to
learn that information
um and then I did speak a little bit can
I stop you I did you just talk you just
talked about the learning management
system correct okay so I thought this
was another
centralized tool of Das
is this something you're implementing on
your own correct correct we needed to
implement a new learning management
system in order to reach external
um Partners to be able to train them so
we launched that external part back in
June of 2022 and we are currently trying
to launch it we're not trying we are
currently going to be launching it
um in the end of summer
for our internal employees okay I I
think that's all good thank you
thank you
um and just some of our key concerns is
the the process the redundancy so really
working with key stakeholders to make
sure that we're reducing our processes
um and as well as making sure our our
outcomes are appropriate
um we had five new administrators in the
last year in HR so where we think right
where we think that that might be a
concern it's also a really great time
for Innovation and new ideas and
diversity of thoughts so we are really
coming together to collaborate and
making sure that HR is there as a
strategic partner for HHS to continue
the Relentless progression forward
um
so so I'm not I'm not under your key
challenges I I note that
you don't have a key challenge touching
on the employee morale or or or Trends
in the employee employment base like for
example do we have an increase or
decrease in sexual harassment
allegations do we have you know other
other kinds of indicators that tell us
something about the morale of the
workforce
um I think we can speak to the vacancy
rate with the vacancy rate could be
um Equitable to the morale right now our
vacancy rate is at 19.6 which is a
little bit lower than it has been in the
past so
[Music]
um
that is definitely our key challenge is
is making sure that we have the people
in the positions to get the job done
um and to to make that
happen for our external customers as
well
so based on all of the the information
that HR has been working on we are
really trying to make sure that we're
working on the engagement and the
recruitment and retention
okay but amongst the existing Workforce
you're not spotting any Trends in
kindergarten it was can you work and
play well with others is our or we have
an internal issues of working and
playing well with each other yeah we
have a big focus on supervisors right
now really making sure that they
understand their role with an engagement
with employees giving them the tools
that they need for Performance
Management giving them the tools that
they need in order to have difficult
conversations is really where HR is
putting a lot of their focus
all right I have one quick one uh I'm
not sure who this would be directed to
but I noticed about 28 of this budget
comes from federal funds what is the
federal government paying for and why is
that a a good number or not a good
number thanks
so if if you turn to the budget briefing
book that you have if you turn to page
you'll see accounting unit 56.77 and
listed there under the funding sources
um we we have a variety of funding
sources that are that are cost allocated
to the um to the team
I'm sorry I'm not quite sure what I'm
seeing in the right place oh sure
um okay page 20.
oh yeah I I apologize yes
that should be
yes yeah I'm on page 20 on funding
source about a quarter of the way down
the page
do you have a question you'd like to
follow up
I it and it looks to me like what you're
saying a certain program some of the
costs have been allocated from General
from from the human resources uh budget
to these other programs and it comes out
to 29 so yeah it's really a common theme
across many of the areas of ocom where
we're able to to cost allocate federal
dollars towards those positions just to
leverage them in a more effective way
thank you
any other questions sure representative
Mooney well thank you Mr chairman thank
you for being here on page 29 of your
slides here I see on the last bullet
implemented the federal vaccine mandate
at the hospitals implemented is past
tense I'm wondering is that still in
effect and are you still working
actively to do and Implement that bullet
item thank you thank you um yes back in
March of 2022 the federal mandate came
into effect so we were able to work with
Glencliff hospital and New Hampshire
hospital to make sure that a hundred
percent of the employee populations were
in compliance and whether 100 is whether
or not they have vaccine or they
received an exemption
thank you very much and you are still
working on that implementation as that
mandate is still in effect you're saying
correct
thank you thank you does that go away
May 21
that that's when the National Emergency
declaration is intended to end does the
vaccine mandate I hate calling it a
vaccine the injection
the experimental injection date is that
when that expires yeah 21 we'll have to
get back to you on that I'm not quite
sure they they separated the some of the
requirements you know with the
disenrollment versus the end of the
public health emergency I'm not sure in
that particular item but we can get back
to you okay thank you
any other questions here
go ahead
thank you along that same line do you
feel that uh with the vacancy rate being
what it is and this mandate being
implemented still is there a connection
at all between the two that you are
missing some great talent because of a
federal mandate there could be that
correlation I haven't really researched
that but there definitely could be based
on the New Hampshire hospital vacancy
rate
thank you and and I think just one
important thing to to point out I just
want to reiterate what what Ellen the
point the CEO of New Hampshire hospital
had spoken to earlier
um that that the labor market in general
particularly for nurses across the state
has been incredibly challenging
um I I know the New Hampshire hospital
associate released a report this past
fall where they had indicated that many
of their contracted staff costs I think
don't quote me on this but I think they
went up by like 113 year over year so so
you're seeing
um and New Hampshire hospital does have
a number of contracted contractors that
we rely upon as well as as our existing
staff so so there are there are a
variety of challenges in that area that
I know face New Hampshire Hospital
Hampstead and glencliffe
all right
um anything else okay do you have any
final words for us
okay I have
12 11.
um this is this would be post time
normally to take a break we have the EAP
and the equity and the program quality
[Music]
um
if I quit asking questions can those be
done in like 30 minutes total so um
today we we have the employee assistance
program
um only and then I was going to have the
office of Health Equity
um and the remaining uh presentations go
on Friday
okay in that case I'd like to go ahead
and get the EAP up and then we'll end up
breaking for lunch until 1 20.
fantastic does that work
and joining me is Michael Lawless the
director of the employee assistance
program
good afternoon I've appreciate the
opportunity to uh
excuse me good afternoon I appreciate
your time and the opportunity to speak a
little bit about the employee assistance
program
so I'm Mike Lawless I'm the director of
the EAP and
we provide confidential Services support
resources to all state employees and
their family members for all three
branches of state government
um I've outlined some of the ways we
interact with employees but I just
wanted to kind of maybe jump to that
second bullet and say that when I
mentioned that we serve All State
departments and their family members
there's a cost allocation formula where
the additional departments outside of
HHS are contracted and pay for our
services
you know
sure and and just to speak to that so
basically when we are preparing the
agency budget in the summer we look at
positions across the state and based on
the number of positions a department has
we then cost allocate a a portion of the
cost to operate the employee assistance
program
it seems like two years ago looking at
this the number that jumped out at me
was four
and I don't know how many how many RNs
do you have doing this service there are
no RNs on staff there's seven positions
including myself in the EAP what's sort
of the normal kind of job or not job
description but job qualifications yeah
so I have a org chart here on page 34
and so my background is I'm a licensed
social worker uh Master's level of
licensed addictions counselor
and um
the four field rep positions that you'll
see on that lower row there's a master's
degree qualifier for those positions but
there's also that combination around
education and experience where a certain
amount of education and the Human
Services field or kind of resource
delivery system might offset some of the
education requirements I could speak to
kind of background and qualifications
for each of our staff if that would be
helpful
so yeah just so you know the cynical
boundary condition you're bumping up
against is that you know in the back of
my mind I'm wondering if this is
something that would best be kind just
contracted out as a as a service you
know why we're doing this in-house and
if we're able to staff these four
professionals
at a hundred percent or whatever the
percentage is I'm just wondering given
the Manpower shortages in the state if
there might be better allocations we
have behavioral health issues all over
the state so so I I I understand the
value of EAP I'm just trying to
re-establish in my mind why this is an
essential internal government function
and whether it's worth our tying down
these scarce resources when we have
Community needs everywhere sure that's a
huge nasty question no I appreciate the
the kind of forthright nature of that
question and I think that's an important
piece for us in terms of how we consider
the work we do and what differentiates
us from other kind of models or
opportunities for employees or their
family members to access supports and
resources and so one thing that I would
say to that is even if we just looked at
the those positions those four positions
there's not strictly kind of a clinical
background if I could frame it that way
in term in other words some folks do
have experience kind of uh maybe even
pursuing licensure or some other kind of
areas of expertise within a behavioral
health model but not necessarily kind of
it doesn't necessarily equate to this is
a person who could be a licensed
clinician somewhere else for that matter
um
what I would say is I think there's a
lot of reasons to support our model and
the value of the work that we do and so
you know just a couple of things that
kind of come to mind quickly
um
one of the things that I think really
puts us in a unique position is that we
in serving All State departments and the
length of service the kind of breadth of
areas that we've all covered in our
Journeys professionally I started with
the state in 2004 in HHS and have been
in HHS since
is that we recognize that there's a
uniqueness to every state culture so
much so that it's not even just that
there's a there's differences in HHS for
say compared to say the veterans home
right it's it's even within HHS you can
go into an agency and work with a work
group and there's another work group on
the same floor down the hall and there's
differences in unique aspects to these
work cultures that somebody outside of a
state system might not necessarily know
I think that part of our work and our
sensitivities to some of those
differences and our openness to trying
to meet folks where they're at and
provide resources that are appropriate
And Timely knowing the state system and
some of the challenges that occur within
the state system I think kind of
positions us very uniquely in certain
ways when we're trying to support work
groups
and individuals
another piece to that is you know from a
personal touch standpoint
um you know some of the work that we do
is connecting employees with mental
health substance use providers in the
community and we certainly have
relationships there but one of the
things that I again I think
differentiates us would be you're not
going to get just a name and a number
from us right and so we're we're state
employees we're citizens of this state
we kind of recognize some of the
challenges that might go along with that
but also the Personal Touch to that
equation is I wouldn't give you
somebody's or I wouldn't give an
employee somebody's name unless I would
feel comfortable with accessing them
myself or even a close love when asking
accessing that person themselves and I
think that's something that you don't
get just by doing an online search and
trying to find a provider in the
community so if we connect somebody with
a provider we've made sure that they
accept their insurance they have
availability in their schedule we've had
that connection with the provider and
and we would feel confident in
supporting this employee and accessing
that provider so those are a couple of
different differences I think around our
services that are not available in other
maybe contracted providers
representative Waller
thank you how many total state employees
are there
the last estimate that I saw was around
11 000 I don't know if that's accurate
okay and how many touches or I don't
know what you call them how many
contacts did you have your how many of
your seven employees how many contacts
did they have with state employees last
yeah so that's a great question and you
know really what that question also
touches on is kind of the Antiquated
nature of our our data management system
which we don't have we're moving to
accessing technology and be being able
to capture information in a more timely
way that reflects the work we do and and
speaks to some of those questions you're
raising
so on average we serve between 550 and
625 clients per year and
even that number is a little misleading
in that it's really just the tip of the
iceberg when I when I throw those
numbers out there what that's saying is
these are clients who've reached out to
us through many different channels and
we've opened a case on that client and
so what that means is
um
we're going to be meeting with them on
average it's between one to six sessions
that we might meet with somebody
but we're also in positions we're
providing resources outside of that a
bit and so I think what a data
management system allows us to do is
really capture in a in a larger way just
how many points of contact we're having
and really the depth and breadth of the
work that we're delivering we are short
a position now we've have we have a
vacant position that we've have an offer
and a start date of March 10th there's
been some transitions occurring in the
EAP I've been in the director role since
October of this past year our previous
director Paula Booth was in the position
for 35 years and so it's exciting time
for us because we you we recognize and I
recognize the need for technology the
need for being available in different
places through different means
and so we're looking at all of our
processes we're developing a
new streamlined approach to Conflict
Management how we kind of
Market ourselves to different
stakeholders within State systems and
describe the services that we offer we
have really ongoing strong relationships
a lot of our referrals come from
supervisors managers HR in different
departments But continuing to keep those
relationships strong and provide
services that meet the current needs of
state employees and their families
I'm gonna I just so you actually have
face-to-face interaction with we do and
absolutely thank you for bringing that
up that's one of the other pieces to
that kind of equation that separates and
differentiates our us from other you
know potentially contracted providers or
something like that
um we appreciate I personally appreciate
the value of that face-to-face
interaction I think ideally when we can
offer that and be present in that way
not everybody wants to take that up for
different reasons
um but when you think about the
complexity the complexity and the
sensitivity to some of the topics that
folks are bringing up their concern
around confidentiality I mean all of
these things are really vital to our
program and our model but trying to
offer that and be present face to face
as much as possible but also recognizing
that there are people who because of
their work schedule because of their
geographic location they just feel more
comfortable accessing us either through
a telephone or some kind of video
resource and we have that availability
as well we've kind of moved into that
and offered that in in conjunction with
face-to-face primarily out of a response
to coven
so do you think and do you work with the
human resources department around this
is being part of retention and
recruitment efforts because you have
this kind of program available to the
employees which really isn't something
that's available
in all Industries yeah it's a word that
was used here a little bit earlier I
believe was reactive right and I think a
lot of the work that we've done through
the years has really been kind of a
reactive nature most of the time folks
reach out to us when there is a crisis
when you know either a personal crisis
or something in the workplace has
reached a level that the path forward is
not necessarily clear but I we certainly
look at our role in retention as well we
are a resource and a support to State
Employees we're at orientations sharing
about the program putting a face to the
program
again to reinforce that face-to-face
piece but we're also looking for any
opportunity we get with all departments
to come back in and reintroduce
ourselves because there is a rebranding
going on in some ways with the EAP but
also because we know people are
overwhelmed when they do those
orientations it's a lot of information
and we don't want to be just somebody
that's kind of out on an island that
folks think oh I got to reach out to
them now because things are falling
apart we can be as supportive and we
often are now a supportive part of
people's work experience that isn't just
when they're in trouble or they feel
like there's no other Road
representative kolorski thank you and
representative Wallner hit on my my
question but I'll take it a little step
further is there any way you can
quantify or make any connection directly
with your services to overall wellness
and and retention
yes I I appreciate that I I'm gonna go
back really quickly to the previous
question I think it really connects well
here in terms of our relationship with
HR certainly we have a strong
relationship with hhshr and you know
kind of varying levels of relationships
with other departments HRS but they're
all positive and they're all at a place
where
revisiting them strengthening them it
makes sense for the employee right
because I think we're all working
together to try to create uh create
healthy workplaces for state employees
and managers so that productivity is
increased which is one of the key
factors that an EAP can bring to a work
group
and so
there there have been some trends that
we've noticed they're certainly you know
with kovid and kind of financial
stresses we have we have state employees
you know when you talk about food
insecurity housing insecurity not many
folks would associate that with state
employees right these are folks you know
for instance might be employed full-time
and you think they might have kind of
deep resources in certain ways but in
reality what we know is that anybody
could experience a problem that any
other individual could right and so
state employees have the same challenges
and struggles that maybe some of the
clients might that we're serving in
other areas of kind of Service delivery
so
I don't know if I completely
answer that question I'm sorry no you
did it I I am seeing a direct connection
to maintaining Workforce by offering
them so that that thank you I appreciate
you bringing bringing it back to that
because I think as we think about the
data management system and um we're
having some conversations with uh HHS
we're again in the green light to
implement a new data management system
those conversations are happening you
know what's exciting about that is while
we have to kind of walk this line around
confidentiality and protecting
confidentiality that's the primary kind
of piece to our program right as state
employee accesses us a manager accesses
us or their family member we're not
disclosing to anybody around who's
accessing us and for what right so when
people reach us reach out to us they
know that their information is safe and
they're protected
but by by having the ability to have a
data management management system and
talk about who's asking accessing Us in
some kind of overarching aggregate data
around some of the challenges that folks
are dealing with maybe even grouping
departments together so we're not
sharing information that could
potentially feel like it's too close to
the line around confidentiality but
allows folks to see the trends within
the state within state agencies I think
that's that's where we want to be that's
the place to kind of be able to refine
the work that we're doing in an ongoing
way and
um
share information about what we're doing
in a more transparent way thank you
you you both asked the questions I
wanted to go to next
um and so so thank you for that and to
come back and and talk about you know my
cynical nature the the optimistic side
goes
um that the EAP I think adds value that
we wouldn't get from a contractor by
being able to interact and engage our
our management our Senior Management to
identify these sort of I mentioned it
earlier the the morale Trends what you
know what's going on in the workforce
that people need to worry about you know
from my point of view we always said you
know there's two things you gotta
accomplish the mission and you got to
take care of the welfare of the soldiers
and so I I think that same
metaphor holds up in the workforce is we
got to get the job done but we've got to
do it in a way in which we take care of
the workforce and so
to the extent that you're able to
protect privacy in a hardcore way
because it's so important to everything
you do
having management visibility into those
kinds of major Trends I think is is
useful absolutely and and I don't know
that we could contract that out
I'd like to think no you know obviously
I'm biased in my position in that way
but even trying to be objective around
it I I think that there's there's a very
unique aspect to this program in in
places that might be challenging to
quantify I think that the data
management system moves Us in that
direction but to your to your point
there around kind of the role of the
manager you know I'm taking that from
what you were saying I mean when
managers are modeling access to the EAP
they invite us in
um we have subtle resources in restrooms
with tear off sheets so people can
access our information in a private way
but when it's modeled by supervisors and
managers it can make a a very important
difference right and so I think those
are all of the pieces when we think
about how we all have a role in creating
a culture where accessing resources
getting uh support it's a type of
incentive that doesn't always attach
well to a financial incentive right when
when I've been a you know work group
where leadership is invested in me it
makes all the difference in the world
and I think that's that's something that
is present in a lot of places and it
makes a difference for employees do you
think if I went to a senior manager in
DHHS and and so you know what what kind
of resources is the EAP program to you
you know would they would they have a
top of mind the idea that you provide
visibility into the overall I'm going to
keep using the word morale until a
better word comes up but
status of the workforce I I would say
yes I I think it's a really important
question you're asking but I think it's
also a complex question because I think
managers continue to get more exposure
to us when they've accessed us in a
certain way or somebody close to them
has accessed us and I think when that
happens it informs the message I think
our part of that is continuing to think
about the marketing piece and getting
that information out around how we can
be supportive putting faces to the
program things like that but also the
fact that we serve all other state
departments
um you know because of the nature of the
program the confidential piece of this
program the voluntary nature to the
program we're often behind the scenes
right that's really our our position is
to help the helper and so you know when
there's uh major events happening in
this state that might look like they
touch dot or might look like they
touched HHS dcyf State Police we're
usually in the background being
supportive and trying to you know help
kind of partner to contain what ever
else is emerging out of that right
because you know we know things like
vicarious traumatization burnout
compassion fatigue are very real all
right so representative Mooney has a
question oh thank you very much your um
chart here on page 36 of the slides is
there any explanation for the color
schemes and I ask because I'm curious if
it's in order of what we most frequently
encounter and even beyond that I see
some of the topics here are quite heavy
and I can only imagine are without a
doubt resourced out almost immediately
upon it being reported so I guess I'll
let you answer from there and see if I
have any follow-ups based on that sure
thank you thank you you know one thing I
would like to say if I could just take a
quick step back would be
um
EAP work is very different than
counseling work as well there's pieces
to the role that you know have some
overlap but
what I find as part of my background was
as a clinician working in clinical
settings and then to move into the EAP
role as a field rep was my initial
position in the EAP it's a different
skill set and so I just wanted to kind
of name that too to go back to the
earlier question around Contracting it
out or something along those lines
there's no there's no real Rhyme or
Reason to the color scheme I like the
idea of framing it that way
um I I had a colleague of mine kind of
look over my initial color scheme and
they went with this so I think maybe
that's that's all I could say about that
piece and then
um
you're really kind of raising maybe two
questions at least how I'm thinking
about it one is around
this referral process some of these uh
kind of resources that we may provide
and how that might turn into a referral
um
so there are certain situations where a
referral to an outside agency would be
the natural course and fairly soon right
and and that doesn't necessarily mean
that uh the problem or the presenting
issues are completely contained so an
example would be if somebody needs a
resource around a legal resource or
child care and they come in naming that
right we might be able to connect them
with a resource around that fairly
quickly we have uh places where we know
there are good resources available we
have relationships with Community
providers and try to bridge that Gap as
soon as possible in that way if it's
requested but what we also are invested
in is a thorough assessment of the
situation and the individual we work
with and so when when you're engaged in
a process like that somebody might come
in talking about a legal resource and
then you find that there's a little bit
more so another example would be
somebody may present and say I'm having
some difficulty in the workplace right
well as we explore that a little bit we
find out that maybe they're feeling like
they don't get along very well with the
supervisor if we explore it a little bit
further we might find that the person
who's in our office is is kind of
progressing in their drinking and that
alcohol is playing a bigger part in the
equation then they were even initially
aware of right and so part of the work
is is a thorough assessment in an
ongoing way whatever whether that's a
one session or multiple sessions
connecting them with the resources if
that's something they're interested in
connecting with but also so looking for
what may be emerging being
aware intuitive enough to kind of
explore in certain areas that arise that
might suggest there's more going on than
what they're presenting initially and
the same thing applies to work groups we
can get called into a work group
somebody might hear oh you know you do a
training around respect in the workplace
or something like that if we came in and
we just did a training because somebody
named it we'd have a work group more
often than not that would say why are
they bringing this in here why aren't
they addressing Mike's behavior he's the
one who's causing problems in the work
group so without a thorough assessment
we may miss the opportunity to provide
an intervention that really lands the
way the manager wants it to land
so so I want to thank you for this
um I I I I want to put us into recess
but I don't want to keep you from saying
something that's really important to you
if assuming we're both here in two more
years
what would be nice also is just a
supplemental slide that tells us
something about the the status or morale
of the workforce you know if you guys
are spotting trends like you know how
how big is the fentanyl crisis affecting
our our employees you know you mentioned
alcohol abuse you mentioned you know
economic stresses
it'd be interesting just for us to to
get that next time I don't don't work on
it now but I'll see you in two years be
able to address that in two years okay
all right all right any other questions
okay so we're in recess until 1 20.
foreign
thank you
good afternoon how are you
foreign
thank you
we um are we online now did they take
the picture down
okay so we're not we're we're not
streaming just yet it says the stream
will resume shortly
is there a bat phone that we can call
I'm not sure let me let me just check
public transparency I don't want to get
started till oh okay we are we are live
okay so it being past uh 120 uh we're
coming out of recess division three
um specifically first up is uh the
prescription drug affordability board
um we have uh Mr White from the
department and we also have
representative Gary Merchant who is the
current chair of the prescription drug
affordability board uh we this is this
is for the members
uh if you've never heard of this it's in
part because this is the very first time
division three has ever seen the budget
everything here before us is kind of
um new stuff and it's on page 1084
that's where the budget can be found
so so with that
um I assume representative Merchant is
going to kick us off are you Mr White
and start really quickly and then I will
hand it over to representative Merchant
um
you you have identified Pages page 1084
as the location for the accounting unit
within the governor's budget there's
also a high level overview in the
presentation from this morning on slide
19 that includes some of the
um authorizing RSA the the nature of the
of the administrative the attached board
as well as some over over a view on the
general purpose
um and and I'm sure representative
Merchant will be speaking to all of that
so
has the department signed the mou
the mou is still actively under
development okay so that's no sometimes
I ask yes or no questions so uh okay
okay
um
what is the purpose of the mou the mou
uh this is really for the members as
much as anyone but the purpose of the
mou is because the prescription drug
affordability board is new
uh there was some decision that needed
to be made about where they would be
attached they've been attached to the
Department of Health and Human Services
they've been attached there for
um basically Administration only there
is zero supervisory Authority within the
Department of Health and Human Services
over any of the actions of the
prescription drug affordability board
they're a wholly independent a kind of
autonomous group except for every two
years they're supposed to come and get
their budget approved other than that
they are extremely autonomous and
um what else did I want to say about
that relationship oh so like for example
in this in this budget that you see on
page 1084 this was voted on and passed
by the prescription drug affordability
Board of which are what six to eight
members and this has been passed through
DHHS and been Incorporated in the
governor's
or went straight to the governor this
time
I'm just trying to get the overall
context of where we are representative
Edwards the flow you're speaking to is
correct the numbers I think could be
spoken to
okay process that you're speaking to
yeah
is absolutely correct oh okay so so
um
I think I think that's everything I
intended to say
um and then we pick up on the slide deck
on page 19 prescription drug
affordability board and representative
Merchant what would you like to tell us
about uh your board
well speaking to the financial side of
the equation not the policy side so I
think is the intent of this committee
um the way because this is a new we we
need to understand the mission and
purpose so that we understand the budget
the mission of the board is to bring
more transparency to the pharmacy supply
chain which goes from the manufacturer
all the way to the patient it's complex
it's
convoluted in a lot of cases
it's something that doesn't have a lot
of transparency to it and when you're
looking for a market that's going to
operate in a for your market economy one
of the cornerstones of any Market is
transparency
and all the sports trying to do is bring
greater transparency to what's happening
in the pharmacy supply chain to give an
example this would help you release some
information I'll be glad to send it to
you
in 2013 Lantus which is their insulin
product had a list price of two hundred
dollars
the net to them was hundred dollars
rebates were paid different people along
the way
in 2021 the list price was 300 and
40 they're about to get to the exact
numbers
their increase only went to 125.
so the question I keep asking people
if the manufacturer is not getting the
Lion's Share of increases
who's getting the Lion's Share
same thing can be said with Eli Lilly as
many documents out there in which the
manufacturers prices have actually gone
down
but the list price with patients are
paying are going up
so the goal of the board is to try to
bring greater transparency into this
supply chain to understand what is
happening
and once it begins to understand what
happens then to develop strategies based
upon the information we obtain
and that's basically the goal the board
is
fundamentally we're dealing with public
domain
public domain folks is paid by taxpayer
dollars
the goal this board is to bring down the
burden to the taxpayer
is find a ways to reduce prescription
drug costs I think we all can agree
we're trying to
help the taxpayer and this is one of the
ways to try to get there so first and
foremost
transparency
develop strategies to bring down the
overall prescription cost
which is a burden to the taxpayers
because of the ones paying for say
employees County Employees school
districts municipalities
so that's kind of the two-prong part of
it
so so does your board have regulatory
Authority and when you create a strategy
how do you implement it
in the RSA 126 BB there are
Powers within the board
to ascertain information that is
necessary for the board to understand
the transparency to it so yes it does
have rulemaking authority which is
granted by the legislative body when
this is passed and it's basically allows
the board to
use its Authority
as much as possible
to work with a entities in the farm
supply chain for the manufacture all the
way to the patient to try to understand
who's getting the bites of the Apple
so is it fair to say your regulatory
Authority is specific in scope to
mandating data
calls that that you ask for data through
regulatory enforcement and they provide
you the regular the data and if not in
your current fee structure you can find
them
if they don't report the data required
by the board
and there's
confidentiality to protect the data
yes the board can Levy a fine
but again I'll go back to when we talk
about confidentiality this is well
thought through
when you're dealing with pricing or cost
factors and so forth a lot of them are
protected through confidentiality
there is a limited very limited number
of people who have access to any of that
pricing data or cost data as well as if
it's ever leaked by anyone else there's
severe consequences
in place to take care of that situation
okay so
um
does this board have any known or
suspected redundancies with other state
operations such as fee setting on this
industry any redundancies in the data
collection effort or any redundancy in
the reporting efforts
the clarification we do not have any
authority over price
none whatsoever that's restricted by the
federal government to the Commerce
Clause
what the board does is has the ability
to get the data so the data with the
board's looking for to utilize to
minimize redundancy is to use the what
they call chisdator which is what the
all-pair claims data at the same time
the board is in a unique position
because it can work with other entities
outside of the state including
University of New Hampshire flag State
Flagship University to help with the
analysis of the data we also have unique
Authority in a sense that we look at the
data for rebates coming back from the
pbms that's something the board has that
no other agency in the state has
currently
thank you
so what to the my yes or no question I I
heard a lot of yes in there is is that
there is some redundancy potentially in
the data collection effort but but for
that example
um the board would first look to see
what's already available before issuing
a parallel or secondary request for the
same data you you're you're looking at
the data that's already available before
demanding it from the private sector
that's correct all right and then I
don't I don't think you address the fees
are the fees
redundant because the the Department of
Insurance charges many of these same
entities to operate in the state so so
to what extent are the fees redundant
I don't see the Visas being redundant
the fees are unique in their own right
um we pay if you look at the same thing
with other agencies you think about my
car
I pay registration vehicle I pay a gas
tax I pay a toll tax has all up in one
vehicle so I guess you have to frame
when you talk about redundancy or
duplication is how you frame it the fee
that we're talking about currently is in
statute
the board is mandated to send out a fee
assessment
so are you are you familiar with the uh
the jail the jail car meeting of Last
Friday where they specifically looked at
the request of the board to
um to have their fees considered fees
and gel car came back unanimously and
said that they recommended the
legislature that we review and make
possible legislative change to the
statute that they perceive the fee
structure
to already be a significant part of
what's going on in the insurance
department and that the fees therefore
from this board
could be interpreted to be taxes
that was the key word could be and I
think what they're looking for is
legislation to clarify that so it's no
longer a good but provide Clarity to it
okay so so the motion that they voted
unanimously on Republicans and Democrats
is that they all came together to
recommend that the legislature review
and make possible legislative changes to
the statute are you aware that these
changes have are being suggested
anywhere in an amendment or in a bill or
we have House Bill 172 which is
before Commerce oops
Commerce has said Commerce took to
retain the bill do exactly what you're
talking about representative Edwards is
to look at different issues that have
been raised since the board's been up
and running are trying to get up and
running and I think that's the place for
stakeholders including this issue to be
addressed is in house bill 172. it's
been retained and for us to sit down
collectively and figure out how to make
it
work legislatively so as the prime
sponsor of HB 172 I'm glad that you're
talking about it uh initially it was met
with opposition from the prescription
drug affordability board and it has the
position shifted to where you now
embraced 172. I didn't say I embraced it
Senator I mean represent Edwards I
embraced the concept of working with
everyone to improve the legislation that
we need to make the board and provide
Clarity to it okay and then what's
happening 172 but clear for those who
aren't here was part of it was to put
the board on ice for two years basically
to kill it that is not what the board
agreed to what the board was willing to
sit down with everyone and all the
stakeholders from legislative people
Pharma pbms insurance companies and sand
cake
how do we work together and how do we
take the legislation we have before us
and make it work
that's what the board agreed to okay and
then on the reporting redundancy
um maybe maybe it isn't all that
redundant but to what extent is the
state and the fed's already providing
reports so that the public has an
opportunity to have transparency into
the prices being charged not not the
costs in the supply chain but because I
think that's what you really want to get
at I think your board is interested in
the costs of the supply chain but but
I'm so I'm just asking about the prices
is there already some level of price
transparency being provided through the
feds primarily not that I'm aware of
there are requires by some of the
federal agencies to try to provide some
called pricing structure out there the
challenge that anyone has when you get
into a prescription drug price is
are you talking about the co-payment
deductible it's so many flavors to the
ice cream it's very difficult for the
uninformed patient to ascertain what's a
fair price
is is is this the predominant
a lever that the board has to influence
price containment is the publishing of
price reports so that various entities
know about the prices being charged so
that they have a better idea of where
they may they may find some negotiation
points you're providing data to for
others who make decisions and negotiate
is that correct
that's the goal okay getting back to the
same thing we're trying to get to is
first and foremost we have to understand
it ourselves right because we can't
develop a strategy unless you understand
what it is you're dealing with right so
so I was listening to um
a White House briefing the other day and
and and they were they were very happy
that they've done a lot to to contain
the price of drugs and so if if the
White House is already working on drug
price containment is is this overall
program simply just redundant here at
the state level what what can this a
tiny little state of 1.3 million do in a
market that's Global that the federal
government's already trying to work on
what what what what what what do we
think we're doing
well many times States act as
Laboratories that's part of what we see
many
opportunities at the state level for us
to create and look at things that we can
do because we're Nimble this is New
Hampshire we're small we all know each
other we work together
that you can't find the federal level so
by working with
different entities
what I call the New Hampshire way
we can probably do things here more
minimally and more quickly than you can
at the federal level and if we find
something that is Meaningful then we can
bring it to the federal level saying
this is what we found in New Hampshire
and be proud of it
you don't have to be huge to make
something work isn't it the case that
Maine is operating on under essentially
the same legislation that New Hampshire
currently is and what what has been the
main experience at being successful and
standing this system up and coming up
with meaningful reports Maine has the
same issue we have here in New Hampshire
it is ill-funded it's not funded
we've for the most part all the work has
been done by the board I'm very thankful
the board members on the board have
volunteered their time right so at this
point in time all the work that we've
tried to put into it to get this board
up and running to do what it was set out
to do
has been somewhat hindered because we
haven't had the resources to really
fully engage all right I've watched that
board a bit and I've been impressed with
the level of volunteerism that's been
driving thank you what they've done and
what you've done you've been a very
effective leader
okay uh I've asked a lot of questions a
lot of those questions I meant to help
just for you that have never listened or
looked at this to have some idea what
we're what we're dealing with
um are there questions representative
Stringham uh if I heard your testimony
correctly it sounds it sounds like um
maybe one of your hunches is that
there's something in the supply chain
that's taken a big bite out of the
pharmaceutical apple and maybe not not
adding that much value but since most of
the traditional kind of data sources
they're either dealing with
manufacturers wholesale prices or the
amount paid at the consumer end
that that
are you thinking that you're going to
kind of be able to see what happens uh
between the manufacturer's price and
then ultimately what the customer pays
and and do you think there's anything
there that that we could act on at some
point in the future
thank you for that question
it's one of the questions we'd like to
ask I mean one of the other things that
I worked in the hospital system for
several years
and
one of the things people advocate for is
having the outside pharmacies sending
the product to the hospital to cut the
cost down
we have at the medical center
refrigerator is full of drugs that we
couldn't use that someone paid for
and why we can't use it is all of a
sudden you have a patient's therapy it
changes either they
can't take the drug anymore the blood
level won't support it whatever it may
be
we've said to the manufacturers can we
send it back to you we don't want it
back
why don't they want it back they sold it
number two give another example of
things that I'm not trying to
get away from the question but
try to explain to people within its
Dynamics is that we had a situation
where our hemophilia program
these are individuals that have a living
disorder they will lead to death
basically so you have Factor you give to
them we took a lot of time literally to
get the smallest possible vial
to the patient why to minimize the waste
so then we went up against an insurance
company that wanted to charge 80 cents
less 80 or 20 less than we were charging
for the unit in the vial
what happened was
they weren't paying attention and taking
the time because the time it intense to
get the smallest vial they standardized
it
so there was a lot of waste they were
sending out 100 units of factor when the
patient only needed 60.
we would take find the 60 unit vial so
on a unit basis
it was less costly to the manufacturer
but the overall cost was a lot higher
these are the examples I'm trying to
explain
that's what the board's trying to get to
is it's not just looking at the overall
cost because of the price of the product
but how the product is utilized could we
somehow work with Physicians to help
incentivize them and educate them to use
less costly generics it supports the
brand name one which is what Farmers out
there promoting all the time
at the medical center we talked about
that with samples and why do Physicians
have samples
simple reason is when they're dealing
with a patient you want the patient to
start in something to have a week or so
to try the drug
I was making the application at the
medical center why don't we give the
docs in the clinic
all the generics they want
they're peanuts
but it was one of those things back to
say these these are things that we could
talk about at the board level
back to represent Stringham is that's
part of it it's not just looking at the
cost of the unit for self but
utilization is a big part of it the
other side of the coin is it could be a
situation where maybe the drug itself
even though it's costly is bringing down
medical costs so you've got to look at
this thing holistically not look at it
myopically
so so the board to your example will
have the regulatory authority to require
data collection and provision to the
state to talk about how much they charge
and how a individual vial of a
particular drug may be utilized yes
thank you so look so let's let's
um are there other questions at the
overall program I want to I want to move
into the revenues here
representative Waller no okay okay so
I'm looking at uh representative yes if
I can drive your attention to something
I passed out a piece of paper
um In fairness to uh DHHS and to Mr
White
um he was submitting data to the budget
requirement LBA based upon an old budget
we put together I think was the numbers
went to fiscal committee many years ago
it seems like many years ago and In
fairness though Mr White he didn't have
the most recent budget the board had
passed the January 3rd so if you look at
the administrative attached
which is section 21 G10
which is also in the handout on the
slide
we're we're I don't see a 21 G10 I'm
lost I I see
normal handout and I see the governor's
budget
those are the two documents I'm seeing
am I supposed to look elsewhere I handed
one out it has a cover page with an
email from representative Merchant and
the last page I believe is the statute
thank you oh okay so when you're saying
G10 this is the this is a statute
correct okay and what are we looking at
at the statute
if you look at the statute if you look
at 21 hyphen G colon 10
B
2C b as in boy boy
okay
all right so so that that that that's
the statutory language of what I said
earlier that the commissioner is
obligated just simply pass through your
budget correct but the budget that
you're looking for on page 1084 was not
built upon what the board approved but
what Mr White had to work from before
then so what you're you're saying is and
let me check with Mr White so what I
what I'm hearing representative
Merchants say is that the for example
the total revenue line
ought to be 451 900 and in the budget
submitted through the governor's process
it's 346 566 basically 105 000 less
which do you understand should be the
correct should be the correct number
when we prepared
um just which one is correct
the budget that is that was just handed
out to the the 450. okay all right I
just want us to be looking at the right
thing okay so so how how would do you
propose we fix the governor's budget or
should we be considering just straight
adoption in division three of the handed
out budget
so I I will be submitting to the to the
um to the committee a series of change
requests included within that change
request series would would be this
updated budget here
okay
so so we don't need to take any action
presumably until we take action on your
budget request proposal budget change
proposal yes we'll submit a summary
document along with the additional
detail for the LBA okay so
um
so now as I understand it as we I want
to I want to drive through the revenues
here as I understand it house Ways and
Means have never looked at
um the any of the fee structures that
are in statute you've given us a portion
of the statute but you've not given us
the portion dealing with fees and it's
my understanding that Ways and Means of
the house has never looked at that part
of the statute is that true
I think it's a fair statement yes all
right so with that
um why don't you walk us through the
revenues
on the revenue side of the equation
for a statute
who are required to assess certain
entities between 100 and 200 or 500 and
a thousand and
the statute there's a floor
the ones that are in the 100
bucket that's the 100 Floor
through rulemaking which is approved by
gel card
we put a range in there between 100 and
the other bucket
which is the wholesalers manufacturers
and bbms
there's a four or five hundred dollars
and through rule making we made a
thousand that's the range we have to
play with
so by Statute we're required to send out
an invoice
for at least five hundred dollars So
based upon the numbers the board was
able to ascertain again would trying to
get as much accurate information about
wholesalers and
manufacturers and pbms and we went to
the pharmacy board and director Courtney
was very kind to try to help us identify
who has a pharmacy license or wholesale
license if you will in the state of New
Hampshire their database could not pull
it
repeat that they did basically not pull
um it's all commingled with different
entities that we could not necessify to
and in order for us to go through it
it's a very manual labor-intensive
process so we went to
State of New Hampshire Medicaid
which is the same as to get what they
call a label as number to identify the
manufacturer and wholesale as we have in
the database and based upon that data we
assume which is a bad thing to do but
that's the best we have
that we'd have X number of entities that
would fall in each one of the buckets
and based upon that then we looked at
the cost to run the board and took the
cost divided by those number of entities
and come up with a assessment fee
so the ones that were in the 100 200
bucket which is only the insurance
carriers
there's 18 of them were assessed a
hundred dollars
all the other ones were assessed at that
point in time seven hundred dollars
based upon our
best guess at what's out there as far as
the people who have to assess the fee on
so what I was what I was looking for is
that you're going to impose a fee
um I'm going to call them a tax from now
on because as I'm reading uh the gel car
minutes uh their uh gel car staff Kim
Reeve
um uh basically said so in looking at
the statute in the legislative history
and the rule the fees might be
unconstitutional because they appear not
to have a benefit associated with them
to the entities paying the fees they're
not fees for licenses they're not user
fees they aren't a tax on property
income they don't qualify as cost
recovery they appear to be a fee for
doing business in New Hampshire but the
legislative history does not talk about
the purpose of the fees it's completely
silent and and this was all in response
to a UNH Professor Marcus horn who had
written ways and means in 2013
suggesting that the Constitutional
authority to impose taxes by the
legislature was limited this that this
peace structure appears to be
unconstitutional based on the people who
really had spent the most time looking
at it so so
um have I said anything that is
factually incorrect yes well please
correct me in PH I think it's one zero
zero I'll
Pharmacy board rules require that any
manufacturer wholesaler has to be
compliant all applicable state
laws that impact what they're doing so
in essence if the Board of Pharmacy will
not provide them a permit because
they're not complying with the
prescription drug affordability board
that in essence is a benefit to the
wholesaler as well as the manufacturer
that's different than the pbms but the
wholesalers and manufacturers
buy Pharmacy rule are required to comply
with those rules and those laws
okay so summarize I I think you said
that
the implication of what you said is that
although your sheet shows some revenues
coming from manufacturers Distributors
PDM and insurance carriers
although gel car unanimously viewed
these as potentially unconstitutional
you think that there may be an exception
to some of these fees being imposed and
that's where I think having the
conversation on House Bill 172 will
provide some clarity to it so so which
of those four categories do you think
still have a viable
wholesalers and manufacturers or
Distributors
Distributors sorry
you see Distributors and who else
manufacturers they're required to have a
permit by the Board of Pharmacy and the
Board of Pharmacy rule requires them
specifically to comply
with rules that related to Business
Association
sure I hate to replan on the ground that
the gel cars spent months looking at
because this is not the first time that
they the fee issue came up with them
right this is stuck on their third time
there was we had a meeting with Mike
Morrow
and we brought up the issue that with
one of the attorneys from uh gel car and
there was some hesitation on their side
it was not brought forward during the
meeting on Friday I was told it's going
to be
um nothing is going to take a lot of
discussion and fortunately it did and I
should have been there and I went
unfortunately I wasn't
but that's one of the things that we
talked about is that if you look at the
pharmacy rule for the permit they don't
comply
then in essence the board cannot give
them a permit
so representative Bill hatch who's a
member of gel Carr and of the greater
finance committee uh part of what he
said is I think most the staff is aware
of my concern over fees as they come in
and that they're and that they're
appropriate because if he has directly
related to the cost of providing a
service if it's not it's a tax and with
this my head exploded about nine times
when I saw what was being assessed no 10
excuse me I was in the hospital so it
was okay there's a little bit of humor
um
but has there been any attention paid to
that because the whole thing is just
upside down in my mind
so so with that Mr Ripple do you have
um my hb2
on this
so it's not in the form of a house bill
2 Amendment but it is an amendment to
House Bill 130 from representative font
that's what you wanted me to handle yeah
let's let's hand that out and I'll
explain to people what that is
yeah
do you have a question you go ahead Mike
thank you
of them of okay
has any of this gotten off the ground at
this point or is it still zero in the
bank and nobody's been hired and no
contracts have been let it's zero on the
banquet but this is at this point in
time all the work is being done by the
board is through the volunteer efforts
of the board members themselves there's
been no Personnel hired although I will
say that the Department of Health and
Human Services has been very generous
with helping us try to administratively
get some of the things done for on our
behalf and when it's up and running what
would the deliverable deliverables be
that we as the public would be able to
see
for the Public's point of view
hopefully within the first 24 months of
the board is finding out how the
transparency if you will within the
board and bringing back strategies
I would say at this point in time it's
most likely in year three or four that
we can actually come back with some
concrete strategies to help the public
out I mean part of it too is one of the
things which is interesting is that
which is I don't understand but it's
reality
all of our public payers don't use the
same PBM we don't leverage ourselves as
simple as that
we don't collectively knows the School
departments use their own PBM the state
employees user pvms why are we breaking
a small state and why not learning from
each other that's a simple step going
forward but again back to your question
we really haven't had the resources to
get it up and running okay so part of
the delivery rules is the
recommendations that the board was
making what we also able to see the data
behind it that you're collecting the
pricing information you were talking
about all that in the aggregate
help out here a lot of the data that
manufacturers would be sharing with the
board is very confidential
and that would have to be retained by
the board but the aggregated data
yes let's the body could see so when you
first sat down you started talking about
I think um insulin yes we wouldn't
actually see
what you just described about insulin
that would not come out of what we would
see in in the aggregate I'm just trying
to figure out what level you're
aggregating is that the whole
pharmaceutical industry gets aggregated
into a couple of numbers or is it per
drug or
it may be by class of drugs and the
information I given to you from sanofi
and from Eli is from the them that's
public data okay that's publicly
available thank you
representative Wallner
thank you
I mean as I'm listening to you I'm
thinking
that the state itself
through the Medicaid Program
probably purchases
a huge share of the amount of
prescriptions that are purchased in New
Hampshire and it would seem that this
would provide for them a lot of valuable
information can you maybe expand a
little bit on my thinking am I
think am I correct because it would be
very valuable to public
to the state for the Medicaid system for
the state employees the counties
municipalities and school districts that
make them if you basically I'm trying to
get to is a
educated buyer
and understand how they should be going
to the marketplace and being and bring
to them a level of knowledge so they can
negotiate on behalf of people in a way
that we can reduce the overall cost the
cost doesn't have to be the unit price
it has to go also with waste
um going from one high cost therapeutic
to another one those are all things that
we could work on collectively to bring
down the overall cost
thank you yep representative
representative Wallner hit my question
again about a savings to the state
thanks I'm Gonna Let You Go first next
time
okay
I think I think I'm I'm ready to draw
attention to the amendment that we just
passed out so so let me give you a
little context on this amendment
um representative leishman also of this
finance committee and I submitted uh two
house bills that are in Commerce one was
HB 130 and the other was HB 172. you've
heard a little bit about 172 but hb130
these two bills together
hb130 was you know just kill the pdab
just kill it the other one
172 was kind of a more reasoned approach
saying that this statute is not cooked
let's hold in a bands for a couple of
years the fee and fine authority of the
board so that we can do a good
assessment on the level of redundancy
that exists and figure out what a best
practice might look like for us to to
move forward to to to some extent
represent a merchant you you're in favor
of the part of 172 that doesn't hold the
hold the authority of the board in
advance but you're you sound like you're
open to an investigation of redundancies
and how we might work together based on
existing programs and efforts I would
say anytime the state can work more
efficiently more effectively we should
consider that but while we're doing that
I would also say the board should
continue on its
journey in this mission to over to do
what we're supposed to be doing and
that's looking at transparency and
reducing overall cost the other thing
too when you're talking about if I may
representative Edwards yeah about the
tax we had a bill before Health and
Human Services to take money from the
marriage license
that's not relevant and what they why is
it not relevant
um because we're working off a testimony
from jail cars saying this particular
fee structure is likely to be
unconstitutional but that goes back to
the question that you're raising so what
I'm trying to get to is that when
someone pays their license forty three
dollars of a 50 goes to another agency
not true I don't find that relevant okay
um okay so
um so again we have in testimony the gel
car unanimous recommendation and the
transcript that led to it
um House Bill 130 was a repeal of the
entire statute but what representative
Hunt's Amendment does is it replaces all
of that repeal language with what is
before you
what I am proposing is that we take this
language and we bring it into hb2
so this is this is kind of one of our
first conversations about this what what
it does is it does to the outcome to you
what it does I'm just introducing the
idea what it does is it does two things
it on line 10 and 11
takes the issue of are the fees
unconstitutional or not it takes the
issue of whether or not we're granting a
highly autonomous board regulatory
authority to demand information from the
private sector and if they don't comply
the power to find them it takes all of
that
out and just says this effort is going
to be funded by the general funds so I I
think I think that is pretty simple and
then lines 12 through 20 there was
testimony from AARP and from new Futures
saying that this was really a great idea
and that they'd like to see it funded so
what lines 12 through 20 do is it
essentially establishes a dedicated fund
so that those interested parties who
believe this is a good idea have a
vehicle for donating their own money
into supporting the budget so that's
what the two things in this in this
amendment do that I would propose
putting into hb2 now if
representative Hunt is successful in
getting 130 out of the Commerce
Committee with this amendment and it
goes and passes the house we can always
pull it out of hb2 because I don't I
don't I don't believe in the belt and
suspender thing if you don't need to do
that but
um so that that's that's my proposal
representative walner do you have a
comment
you know I think you just answered it
because I I wanted to know where one
third I knew it was in Commerce but I
didn't know what its fate had been
whether it was still alive whether it
had been amended what it happened very
much alive uh representative hunt what
he's told me
is that uh he's got a handshake deal
with his uh minority partner that if
they ever get to the point in Commerce
of recognizing that there's a 10 10
split on a bill they'll retain it
and so he's been thinking
that this is likely to be 10 10 on on
party lines
but what's new is Friday gel car came
out unanimously
saying that the the fees were an issue
and I think that just makes this
amendment for representative hunt and
130 prescient because it it sort of
Rises to the occasion raised by gel car
in my view
go ahead so let me ask you this if
this amendment doesn't
if Commerce decides not to accept this
amendment
when we then continue to attempt to put
it in a house bill too
so so I think it depends you know we we
as kind of an interesting one when we're
talking in committee but if Commerce uh
ends up hung up on a 10-10 vote and they
choose to retain it I think we still
have uh independent action without being
biased by their vote nor informed
neither biased nor informed by their
vote to push this into hb2 based on our
own interpretation of the jail car
caution to have the legislature review
the fees
so so I I'm I'm ready to you know talk
about this and uh get it we don't have
to vote on hb2 today but I just don't
want to be
um hiding anything from division three
that that that's my intent is to
eliminate the unconstitutional tax
structure that's in current statute and
replace it with the general funds to
support an approved budget
and to allow the creation of a dedicated
fund so that those members of the
community who are passionate about this
can put their own money into it
so
yes ma'am
thank you I just have a question
um
looking at a new
use the word Distributors and
manufacturers would be the ones that you
believe can pay into this I assume this
hasn't started yet
all right that
no funds have come in yet and okay I'm
gonna just confirm that
um and we've also heard that
AARP and new Futures think this this is
a great idea is there any feedback from
any of the groups that would be paying
these fees as to
their Acceptance non-acceptance in my
opinion I'm just looking at it we talk
about buckets those look like drops in a
bucket for these organizations what
we're talking about here
during the board meetings and so forth
we did hear from Pharma the
pharmaceutical manufacturing company
they were not concerned about the fees
at all
what they were concerned about is
confidentiality of the information and
we
modified the rules to accommodate their
concerns over the confidentiality that
was addressed but we have not heard from
Pharma I mean from Pharma and the
manufacturers orphans Distributors the
only ones we've heard from is the
insurance companies
and and just to
follow up on that and you said that
their share is a hundred dollars
correct two hundred dollars correct
and there's only 18 of them
thank you but then there are others that
are paying 500 so it's it's a bit Yeah
tiered representative Waller
so you've seen the amendment I don't
know if you'd seen the amendment before
we came today
yes I have and
can you give me an idea of how the board
would feel about this amendment what
would the board think about this I can't
speak for the board because we didn't
talk about it at the board collectively
I would say based upon this information
um there may be some reluctance on the
board part of it is inside of here is
not trying to pin it down but
if we're looking for the general fund to
fund it there's nothing here requires
any dollars so every single year we go
through a budget cycle
we're constantly going through a process
and trying to understand do we have any
money to do the job or not
because there's nothing in here to
specifies it's going to be a quarter of
a million and a half million if you want
to put them a half million dollars in
there and it stays that way I think the
board would probably live with it but
right now there's nothing in this
amendment that addresses that issue
doesn't the part that says you can raise
it no you're right the the part that
says you can raise 125 percent of your
approved budget would be stricken by
this bill yeah
um but the problem you just said that
you would have to worry from budget to
budget how much money you're going to
get
you just describe our entire state
budget every every Department what I
mean what makes this department
exceptional to the point
where we should permit
a probably unconscious I mean the
industry doesn't care about whether
something's constitutional or not that's
our job if this is an unconstitutional
tax
uh why why should this board be held out
as something special and unique
if the comment about the
unconstitutionality of the tax versus
the fee was never raised by the Pharma
was now raised by the wholesalers
Distributors the only entities that
raised the issue with the insurance
carriers
so well in the legislature in the
legislator and and the legislature's
product I don't mean to argue with you
but I I I I withdraw that sorry
uh representative Wallner
so this bill passed in
2020. 2020. and at that time was there
any discussion about the fee
and unconstitutionality of it no matter
of fact if I may take a second
representative Waller it never was
discussed even a jail card came in
literally of the 11th Hour 59th minute
15 minutes before the jail card meeting
that's when it and that had been around
since 2013.
so as we mentioned earlier in the
legislative history this bill has never
been to Ways and Means and Ways and
Means is typically the subject matter
expert on the constitutionality of taxes
and fees that's the sort of their
jurisdiction so this bill has the
statute is bypassed subject matter
experts and Ways and Means and in
finance in previous years so so that's
that's kind of one of the issues that
representative leishman and I have had
when this first came in front of the
fiscal Committee in January of last year
so
representative Edwards again with House
Bill 130 I would make the strong
recommendation that we pull it into
house bill 172 and talk about this issue
collectively and not try to do it
piecemeal that we look at various issues
that stakeholders have raised and we do
it
in a sense of holding stakeholder
Community because to deal with one piece
of it versus somebody else I think the
legislative body would be better off if
we all come together
collectively and talk about the
respective issues and how we can resolve
it with a bill versus trying to go back
time and time again to fix something
because we didn't take the time on front
end to do it correctly so both 130 and
172 belong to representative hunt in his
committee so uh a division three in
finance can only do with what we have in
front of us is it that's why I think
this language that Commerce is going to
consider is for this amendment is is
great material for hb2 but that that's
my perspective
so
um
so rather than taking any kind of a
straw vote on that and because this is
the first time that several of the
members have seen it I I I'm just going
to leave it with you because we'll have
time to discuss it when we talk about
hb2 more in the future but I just want
you to know that I want to end the
possibility of an unconstitutional tax
and I want to end the authority of this
board to autonomously issue fines if
they don't get the information they want
and the time that they want from the
private sector that is a extreme
Authority that I think is too onerous to
to leave in an independent board's hands
they need to be accountable
all right so let's uh let's start
getting into your budget
I think you want to hire two people I
want I think you want to hire an
executive director at a base salary of
118 000 and you want to hire an
administrative assistant for
um over forty five thousand is that
correct
and that's correct
okay so Mr White and the budget proposal
that that the change proposal you would
submit I see on page 1085 uh
unclassified positions I see one would
would would the
with the change proposal reflecting this
have one and one so for a total of two
the
uh essentially we'd have to create a
class 10 for the classified
yes okay
all right
okay so
um representative Merchant uh the total
of all the payroll lines is 242 thousand
dollars
um
it's nearly a quarter million dollars
do you want to explain what these folks
would be doing that adds a quarter
million dollars of value to the taxpayer
yes the executive director's
responsibility is to work with all the
other state agencies as I mentioned
before is how to weave it together
to take
the various resources we have within the
state so we don't have redundancy that
we can actually at that point in time
leverage what we do have so the
executive director is going to be
responsible for being the liaison to all
the other state agencies to find out
where we can benefit collectively so we
don't have
again back to that word redundancy that
we try to minimize that number two it's
also working if with other folks another
pdas throughout the country try to
acknowledge there learn themselves
because they're the ones going to be
really tasked with understanding a black
box it's a lot of research a lot of
understanding
the administrative person is not so much
there to help them but help coordinate
the things like
are we getting the license fees are we
getting the registrations in on time are
we getting things the the data requested
by the board is it coming
forward is the advisory Council up and
setting as it up and running I mean
that's it's administratively helping
them so we don't pay somebody who's an
executive director to do administrative
work their role really is to be the
captain of the ship and work with all
the other facets of our state government
along with
the industry itself to begin to become
more knowledgeable about the black box
and bring transparency to us sure so if
you had this money on one July
and given the workforce issues in the
state
what do you think it would take for you
to get these people identified and hired
one when would you need to start paying
them
wishful thinking would be that I would
have somebody on board July 1 the
reality is most likely not the
individual that we're looking for and
the unique knowledge that they would
require would probably be wouldn't be
until sometime into the fall see I'm not
a lawyer but I don't even know if you
can post a position until it's been
approved and this budget in the earliest
is going to be approved sometime in June
so so do you think you could have it
posted that quickly in July 1.
that's a good question
that's the question do you think you
could really have it posted if you
I don't know all right so there's
probably a higher lag in here most
likely it's going to be some degree of
higher lag in there yes okay so
um The Contract Services
133.5 what is that for is that one
contract or multiple contracts it's
predominantly one contractor we reached
out again this has to go through an RFP
uh it has to go through GNC
so it's going to be a process we're
looking to reach out to the University
of New Hampshire they're doing work now
with the Department Health Human
Services to analyze some of the data so
we're trying to see if we can build off
in that contract without having to
create another one but again it has to
go through the rfe process
so the contract Service is looking at
helping us develop a methodology so once
we begin to understand what's in the
black box is then how do you start
developing methodology
to develop the strategies and the
methodology we create because this can
be scrutinized it has to be able to
withstand the scrutiny of people and
entities looking at it so if we set a
spending Target it has to be both upon
sound
information sound process and that's
where you need to bring consultants in
who have
the knowledge in this space to do it and
help the board out it's not to do so
much the data analysis but help us
understanding how do we use the data to
develop the targets we have to set
within the statute so so is there a
deliverable or is the deliverable in
this case advice and a support and
basically an extension of the subject
matter expertise of the two people the
deliverable
one of the deliverables is helping us to
find a methodology to create a spending
Target
because that's a Nostalgia is we have to
be able to go to different public payers
and saying we think this is a reasonable
spending Target
so so would that work wait until your
cooperation with the other state
agencies took place and we've figured
out what the redundancies were I mean
are are you ready to sing today that
that's what you need in that deliverable
I would say I need to hire somebody to
help us understand it because right now
we at the mercy of volunteers we don't
have the time to really get into it if
we put something into the budget because
we do realize that we have to have
contracts with people to be able to do
the
okay legal services in year One what
kind of legal services are you well I
put that in because I wasn't sure about
the department
as far as DHHS and mou is do we have to
reimburse maybe we don't back to the
AG's office the AG's office says the
attorney that helps support us so do we
as an entity like we do the department
of health Team services do we have to
pay back to the AG's office where the
legal services we use for them
so let's say you do and and that if you
needed to it was it this is a fine place
for it but what legal services do you
anticipate in Year One
when we go through rule making like we
did last time is helping us understand
we do rulemaking
is guide us from a legal point of view
because this is jail car basically
helping you navigate jail car it could
be jail cards helping us navigate the
mou with the Department of Health and
services navigating any contract we have
say for um the University of New
Hampshire so this the business side of
the equation but this legal side of the
equation so you have a contract you have
to have a contract based upon the
business business principles but you
have to also have an attorney to look at
it from a legal protection point of view
okay subscriptions ten thousand dollars
that is for the what they call medi-span
it's a database medispan medicine okay
it's a database
okay who do you rent that from and do
you know 10 000 is the right number
um based upon what
we heard from the Department of Health
and Human Services and people within the
department that's what they advised us
would you spell that m m a d i i I'm not
I'm dyslexic are you getting it
s-p-a-n
it's one of it it's it's a way for us to
go into public data to find out what is
out there for pricing and so forth to
help guide the board when it's doing its
work okay you got 50
000 for dhh oh I missed the white
speaker that one mou do you want to
speak to them that's why absolutely
um in RSA 21g10 uh it indicates that um
when the department provides support and
services to any administratively
attached board we use a cost allocation
system we base this number based on
prior experience with other
administratively attached boards based
on the level of servicing that we were
projecting
in that case should that 10 000 Legal
Services be included in that mou number
I wasn't involved in the development of
this budget so I think I need to have an
offline conversation to understand what
assumptions were made there okay so
you'll have that assumption clarified
when you do your change request correct
okay
um
was was there in the in the governor's
budget there was uh travel money I don't
see travel money here I see an education
slash conference for 4 000.
oh wait a second where's that what page
is that
okay
the
the one that was submitted I skipped
over it's only a thousand dollars
I see it that was my error education
conference was what's that it that's
basically for somebody to
either continue their education they
could be going to a conference
um knowledge sharing
professionals have a but there's not an
identified conference well I'd leave it
up to the the individual if it's hired
to decide which one they should be going
to and not try to micromanage it
okay so I think
I understand your revenue and your
expenses are there any questions on the
very first budget proposal presented by
the pdab
representative Mooney thank you very
much and thank you for being here
um I have not and I'm not familiar with
RSA 126 hyphen BB colon 2. but are there
reporting requirements from your board
and if so how frequent
there are
not per se reporting requirements that
you're probably thinking about what we
are required to do is with set annually
a spending Target which in essence is a
report
so we have to at that point in time for
the public payers give them a Target and
saying this is what we think is a
reasonable for you to be spending
so that's required in the statute but
one of the other things that came out I
want to talk about House Bill 172 I
think to your point representative
Mooney is that the department Health
Human Services oversight committees
probably the board should go back to
that committee
and provide some updates to the to that
oversight committee whether it be done
annually or
every six months I mean it's up for the
discussion with the legislative body
what they want to hear from the board
so I'm curious on page 20
no that's 19 of um the the Commissioners
slide deck
the last bullet the purpose of the board
is to identify I'm just curious who the
author of that paragraph is is that in
statute or is that uh ad hoc
I believe that was based off of what was
in statute I don't think we yes based on
statute
so this if I went to the statute this is
a quote
or or somebody took the statute and
wrote this freehand
it is
it is partly a quote what you'll see
within the parentheses there any
division state county or otherwise
um that section is not a direct citation
of 126 bb5 Roman 1A but the remainder of
that statement is
who who wrote who wrote this um uh this
was prepared by my team by your team yes
okay
so why would they add words to the
statute that didn't exist I'm assuming
what they were doing and I can verify
this in a second was using the public
pair definition from 126 bb1 Roman 6 and
and they inserted the public pair
definition there okay all right well so
those are my questions before we finish
this is are there any questions from the
committee
uh represent Waller I just have one for
uh representative Merchant
what what kind of qualifications are you
looking for in the director
um the qualifications has to be at least
the Master's Degree preferably some
other doctorates somebody has worked in
the pharmacy supply chain is
knowledgeable in the space
the
one who's running the Maryland Board is
both an attorney and a pharmacist
um so the qualifications that we're
looking for are relatively High
so it's both not just the educational
side of the equation which is going to
be important
but more importantly the knowledge they
have of the pharmacy supply chains so we
don't start from scratch that they can
basically hit the ground running
thank you
okay
um again parting parting words for us
because we're about to wrap on this for
now
I just want to thank the committee for
your time
um if you have any questions about the
board or anything to do with the budget
and self-worth by all means feel free to
call me I think the mission of the board
is something we should embrace we may
have a discussion about how to get there
but I think overall what I've heard time
and time again from most stakeholders as
well as most legislators is the intent
and the mission of the board is
something we want to support
all right with that uh we're going to
adjourn the division three work session
on the department
and we're about to go into a joint
session with division one to discuss
hb49
so this would be a good time to take a
quick break while division one shuffles
in